Okay,
this is how we're going to start off.
We're going to build today.
Ladies and gentlemen,
we're going to start slow and we're
going to build gregory.
How are you buddy?
Joseph,
we have to talk about Jesus.
We got elite trip.
We were both overlapped in Italy.
I fucking love the bit you're doing
about the guy over there.
I don't want to give away,
but say I,
I'll just say sky.
I saw a guy walking down the street and
my sister pointed out,
uh,
he,
the automated over there,
like you see Italian Americans are kind
of animated Italian Italians,
guys walking down the street on his cell
phone and I don't know what he's saying.
And he's,
and he's,
he's getting so animated.
He stops,
puts his briefcase down so he can pinch
his fingers together and wave his hand
up and down with a cigarette dangling.
And have you seen the Italian Dan
Bilzerian?
Now there's an Italian version of Dan
Bilzerian.
She got Dan Bilzerian,
who's this super wealthy poker player,
gambler character,
international playboy type dude,
worth fucking hundreds of millions of
dollars and just every picture is him in
a jet and him getting blown by 50
chicks,
you know,
well there's this guy in Italy and all
he does is take videos of him and it's
super hot.
Fiance dancing and apparently he's a
huge celebrity in Italy and he's an
older guy.
Yeah,
we stopped that.
He's actually my age,
but he just looks old or 50 year old
millionaire is cooler than Dan
Bilzerian.
Oh,
he's fucking rip.
Shredded,
tatted up.
And he could dance.
Go to his instagram page.
One of them became famous.
No,
that's not it.
It's one with him and the girl it
became.
Yeah,
that's this page.
Um,
I'll tell you,
uh,
scroll down.
Keep scrolling down.
No,
no,
no.
Just scroll down a little.
I'll tell you which one to click on.
He's got a gang of them on his page,
but one of them sort of caught fire on
the Internet and people started paying
attention to it and then it became this
big thing.
Little bit more.
It's all just pictures.
No,
there's some fee.
That's it.
The lefthand side.
That's one of them.
Yeah.
That's just one of them.
This is not even the best one.
He's been,
I mean it's like him and his girl like
dancing and she's hot as fuck.
And uh,
even though he's my age,
this dude is like,
well,
leathered from the son.
Yeah.
He's constantly out in the sun.
He's never worn sunblock in his life.
No.
Or Has Shea?
Did I give a fuck?
Look at the body on her.
Oh my God.
He's in great shape to man feet.
Beautiful thing.
What I mean,
but I mean,
this is a,
this is what it is.
A dude basically in his underwear with a
girl in her underwear and they're all
sweaty and dancing around on a,
on a gorgeous rooftop rooftop villa with
a pool.
Yeah.
They're just super bawling through super
and publicly.
Yeah.
Sometimes I see rappers and they've got
the yacht.
They've got all that,
and then they've got this down.
Our face painted on embryo.
Looked like,
dude,
do you realize you're on the roof of a
fucking,
you know,
a yacht and you got beautiful women
standing around jazz music.
What do you get involved?
A little bit harder out there.
Chris Brown here.
What happened?
I just saw that he was uh,
arrested.
I don't know,
I um,
I turned on the TV yesterday at noon and
this is the first I'd heard of it.
There was a standoff at his house and I
was like,
what?
Like Damn,
what the hell is this?
So apparently they had been there since
3:00
in the morning,
so they'd already been there for nine
hours.
Wow.
Yeah.
And the,
they didn't have a warrant but they were
surrounding his house and the helicopter
footage of it.
So the shown it on the news,
helicopters circling,
Chris Brown's house,
cops all down the driveway.
He lives on a cul de sac.
So there's all these cops all lined up
down the street.
Cops everywhere.
Like a ton of cops.
Like they're responding like this is an
armed dangerous guy.
Like they would any other armed
dangerous guy.
And it's just him.
It's just him and apparently some girl,
he might've had some friends at home
with them,
I don't know,
but I'm pretty sure it was just him and
he said they were at some party or
something like that and the girl said he
pulled a gun on him.
He pulled the gun on her and um,
so I guess she called the cops and you
know,
there was more people there that had a
story I heard was that a friend of his
had a bunch of jewelry out and party
made.
Her and her friend went to look at the
jewelry when they start asking about the
jewelry,
Chris freaked out on him and said,
get the fuck out of my house.
I don't want you to girls here anymore.
And one of his friends grabbed her phone
and tried to say like,
we don't,
I'm not gonna give it back to you to
sign an NDA.
And then she said she wouldn't do it.
Snatched her phone around.
Now this was according to her.
That too.
So it is,
it's hard out there for a pimp.
Sketchy.
All around.
Yeah.
She all around,
right?
I mean,
it's like,
what do you say about something like
that?
Like what the fuck really happened and
why is your friend showing jewelry?
Her house.
I mean every detail of it is twisted.
It's also stupid.
So he makes a ton of videos and puts
them on instagram.
Chris Brown.
Yeah.
Have him,
you know,
given his side of what things are and
he's keeping it real essentially.
Yeah.
There's videos and it's his and he's
smoking a cigarette.
It's,
it's very sketch.
So they didn't hold on him.
They arrested him and rest of the fuck
out of them.
Yeah.
Uh,
I don't know if they kept them,
but I mean they went in and they booked
him for assault with a deadly weapon or
attempted assault with a deadly weapon.
Is that what it is?
How long until he.
He's saying that the cops were roughing
him up.
I'm sure they have video footage of
everything.
They wouldn't be crazy.
That would be crazy not to.
Yeah,
something like that.
Like who the fuck is under age cousin
and then piss on somebody.
No,
those are Kelly.
How you could fit like three different
black people.
I don't know who fuck their cousin,
but r Kelly was peeing on.
People didn't use to put less lately and
molest them.
No,
that's the other guy.
That's bill cosby.
Oh,
got it.
Jesus Christ and that crazy.
Like,
what the fuck man.
I can't tell black people heart.
I just realized that you confused Art
Kelly and Chris Brown.
Is that bad when they,
they are off by like 15,
20 years.
What if one of them is our age?
Our Kelly is,
he's 49.
And when did he play basketball?
He didn't play basketball.
He's a singer.
A singer.
Got It.
Yeah.
Um,
I don't know any of his songs other than
the really hilarious ones.
What?
Have you ever heard real talk now?
Oh my goodness.
I wish we could play it,
but we'd get.
We'd get the boot off the youtube.
I got to play it for you.
It's fucking brilliant.
Fucking brilliant.
And it's humorous.
Not on purpose.
Oh No,
it's,
it's all about him getting in an
argument with a girl on the phone.
See if we could play.
Part of it will play part of it.
Why did they quit?
Part off Youtube.
Yeah,
dude,
they have a computer that does it have
you play someone song?
You don't have permission.
If you show a video,
you don't have permission,
you know,
people own their property.
So if some guy has a video.
Here was an issue with.
There was a guy like wildlife videos.
Carmen had a video of a crocodile
walking across a golf course.
Do you see that giant crack?
We're alligator.
Huge,
huge.
Like 15 feet long.
Enormous.
I put it up on my facebook because I
just retweeted like a youtube video that
somebody posted up or I'll put a link up
to elect,
check this shit out.
That's all he did.
I didn't upload it to facebook and
facebook took my account down for like
three days.
No Shit.
Yeah,
they wouldn't let me post a video for
three days.
So what's the lesson there is somebody
owns the sweet.
Anything.
It's not.
I don't.
I don't think it was correctly done.
I don't know.
I think maybe I retweeted someone who
had illegally put it up or something
like that.
I don't remember the full details of it
because I retweet shit constantly when
people send me something that's cool.
I'm like,
I would want to see this.
So I sent it to everybody.
That's.
Yeah,
they shouldn't penalize it.
Retweet.
That's crazy.
I mean maybe I put a link up to the
video,
but I definitely didn't upload the
video.
Somebody else's video.
It was on,
you know,
whatever it was,
whatever.
Live leak.
Who knows what the fuck was on,
but somebody decided they own that video
and it's got more than $20 million hits.
Now.
It's like when a video becomes that
popular,
I think they can make a fuck load of
money from it.
Yeah.
It becomes like a television show,
right?
You know.
So if we play this will get kicked off
of Youtube,
but you got to hear it.
So this part is not on Youtube,
right?
People can't hear it.
This is Chris Brown.
No,
you got two things going on at the same
hint.
You know Jamie,
Jamie Young,
Jamie's captain tabs,
he loves them tabs.
This is
for the people listening with this is is
he's sitting there,
he's got a box of cigars,
is opening up.
He's got sunglasses on and he says,
I'm just going to be real.
It's got Gucci Sunglasses that say Gucci
across the front.
They have to and so he's pouring himself
a nice drink.
He's got a stoke ego and he's calling
this girl down.
I was at a club with who?
What was keeping a rail?
It's called real talk,
real talk.
I'm trying to establish what's wrong and
while he's talking to her and another
girl braiding his hair because she saw
me at the club with some other bitches.
Tell me girl,
did she say there were other guys there?
This is.
That is.
Well there other guys there will tell me
this back that up.
We going to hear that again.
It's not even a lyric gets shifted.
Him Ranting to a friend with a beat
under it.
Just play a little bit of that just by a
little bit.
How the fuck shit.
God Damn it.
He's good.
Like he's living in it.
It's like if he's a brilliant comedian,
I'm just a brilliant Andy Kaufman Times
a hundred and he's committed to this
character and he's like literally going
out peed on girls on video just for this
character like that,
that debt is.
He's like delivering it in the most
subtle of parodies.
Well,
when we this then when I was down in ice
to write for a show,
you know,
tei,
the rapper,
he's like an Atlanta based kind of
gangster rapper.
Arcelio has 40 more chapters of trapped
in the closet.
Planned what's trapped in the closet.
He didn't write a book.
No,
it's way better than a book.
It's like a musical,
like a story gets told over a rap
musical with the most proponderous
lyrics of all time.
Like he wrote them five minutes before
he decided to film this whole thing.
It's a south park parody to the whole
thing on it to south park did a whole
thing with Tom Cruise.
Tom Cruise is in the closet.
It was like,
Oh yeah,
I saw it was like a scientology gay
double whammy attack.
Oh,
and they use trapped in the closet.
That's already 33 chapters to it.
Oh Jesus.
So it's doing well.
Do People love him?
Yeah.
They love that guy.
Was it?
He's like the bump and grind guys at
him?
No.
Is that him?
And I believe I can fly from space jam.
Oh,
that's it.
That did it.
That touched a lot of people's hearts.
Jamie.
That was his song.
I believe I can fly out.
She's got a good voice.
Yeah.
Oh,
he's got a great voice.
Yeah.
Got a great voice.
But God damn that video is awesome.
Yeah,
that Shit's awesome.
And he just imagine waking up in the
morning and being that guy and deciding
I'm going to wear that purple Fuchsia
studded jacket today.
I'm going to get high immediately.
You could do it.
You can kind of.
Anybody could come and do it.
When did the pitches get there?
It's a good question.
Like,
do you call the bitches or do they just
show up?
Um,
I think they just come with the contract
or something.
Yeah,
right.
You don't get your security deposit back
if they're dead.
They just,
they're just there.
Yeah.
Like the,
it's like a natural ecosystem,
you know,
if you look at a,
a reef,
what does it happen as,
as crabs,
as plankton,
feeder fish,
or do you have expensive cars?
Yes.
Earlier mansions.
This is jewelry involved?
Yes.
Okay.
Well the bitches will be there.
They'll find their way.
They heard it,
heard about it.
It's,
it's like they've got a friend at the
jewelry store gone get his bag of
diamonds going 30 to 100 ml holidays.
Smell it in the air.
There's a certain kind of Hoochie Mama
that just smells that stuff.
Yeah.
She just shows up.
Yep.
That's what I mean.
If studying nature,
it's like an outsider looking at humans.
That's what you should do is like a bear
grylls kind of a show.
But it's just you exploring like social
phenomenons,
like r Kelly,
treating them like they're in the wild
will treating.
There's a lot of stuff you could treat
like that if you just studied it like as
a scientist.
Right?
Wouldn't you want to get involved with
like Rodeo culture?
Like tell them you wouldn't want to be
around the people that are like ultra
Rodeo.
People that love Rodeo,
hang out with them.
I'm like,
be with them like everyday for like a
couple months,
like Lutheran style.
Embed yourself.
Like Luther,
when he does these documentaries,
he goes to a place like you went to
Africa for like three months.
Yeah.
And hung out at a hunting camp,
you know,
and hung out with these people until he
annoyed them to the point where they got
mad at him,
gave him some good footage.
No Shit.
Oh,
that's what he was looking for.
Not really.
He looking to understand it,
but after a while the best footage came
out of this guy.
Just getting like really pissed at him.
Yeah.
But I think that if you embedded
yourself in like a.
okay,
how about a coal mining town?
Embed yourself
in a coal mining town.
There's some for the music data.
Local girl.
He's got even worse job.
Get a job at the end.
Work and live in the mind for a couple
months.
Right.
And then.
And then do,
do something on that.
See,
there's some weird pockets of humanity
in this fucking country.
Yeah.
Just in this country,
like forget about the world.
Well,
what about the ultra rich go into a
country club in West Palm beach that has
no black members and it's all like
fortune 500 ceos and old fucking money.
Just blue blood dripping out of them.
Wow.
He could get access to that here,
but what kind of stock tips are going on
and that steam room,
you know,
they're,
they're.
They are the reptilians.
They're deciding when the market goes up
and down,
interest rates,
foreign policy.
It's all happening in that fucking steam
room.
Wow.
There's a lot of that,
right?
Golf Games.
Yup.
How much gets done on golf courses?
Like you almost have to play golf.
If you're like a big time businessman,
man,
you almost have to play golf,
which is time consuming is shit.
Five hours out there.
You've got to get there.
Then there's a drink afterwards.
It's a whole fucking day.
It.
That's the thing about golf is it
requires the money to join and then also
the wealth to not have to be working
that day.
That's a giant chunk of time.
Yeah.
When Obama Plays Golf,
he played golf for that long now because
they'll clear the course for him and
then they have a four caddies who were
guys that stand up about a hundred yards
ahead of you and they spot your ball,
so by the time you drive up in the cart,
he's already got the ball and he's
running ahead and so they can.
They probably get around in about two
and a half hours.
Jesus Christ Bush used to,
used to run golf.
It was this.
I'd never heard of the sport before,
but his family does it.
You Jog and hit the ball and keep
jogging.
What?
Yeah,
he would play.
He would play golf five minutes.
You're the horse.
I've never even heard of such a thing.
Yeah,
it's like,
you know,
time conservation Bush style.
Well that was one of the only big
benefits of golf was that you had a walk
the course and the course is a lot of
exercise and you get your exercise in
and people are like,
Eh,
not really into.
The deals are being made back in the
car.
I just want a cart,
it's hooked up with a stereo and a
cooler.
I'm Rodney Dangerfield on this shit.
Oh,
how drunk are you allowed to get on a
golf course?
Well,
you know,
I play golf and I play a lot of these
celebrity tournaments,
which is like,
you know,
they'll have 18 groups that are going
out and then each one gets a comedian
added into the group just to fuck around
and,
you know,
entertain.
I don't know if you had to take,
but you know,
they just like to meet somebody and uh,
they have these bark,
these,
a cart bars that go around with the
fucking hottest chicks you've ever seen
in bikini tops.
And they pull up with hard liquor,
beer,
everything.
And they,
uh,
they flirt.
And these guys I played with guys that
like literally are crawling off the
course when they're done the so shit
faced.
And then you go to the dinner and they
drink more and then you get up and tell
jokes.
Oh my God.
Try to make them laugh after that shit.
Yeah,
it's a riot.
Wow.
Yeah.
I always pictured golfers.
I always picture him like Ted Kennedy,
like that kind of face.
Yeah.
Writing big fucking overwhelmed tissue
face like so much inflammation.
Your skin is just running from your
skull.
So dignified and older gentleman.
This spider veins?
Yeah.
The front of the nose is just a giant
vein wilderness.
There's a bunch of those older guys that
get that from the booze and the heavy
bag that Newt Gingrich guys got that
shit going on too.
He's got that.
Uh,
I have a couple of whiskeys and night
look,
I used to caddy at a country club.
Oh,
what the fuck was I like to workout.
I mean a golf course is about six miles
and you got to heavy ass bags back then
everybody had leather bags and you know,
extra golf balls in there.
So I'd have to have those.
I weighed about 125 pounds and I would
just,
just like a fucking mule up and down
hills and sometimes you get a loop.
Like I had this one guy and he goes,
uh,
he was a ship Golfer anyway.
And I,
it took me all day to find his ball.
And then he hits one out of bounds,
like over a fence into the woods and he
goes,
where's my ball?
I go,
it went in the woods.
He goes,
we'll find it.
I go,
you hit it,
you find it.
And the guy fired me on the spot so I
just quit.
And I didn't carry his bag.
I just put his bags down,
fucking walked in.
Dr Angela.
Lily used to get shit faced and then get
into his car.
The parking attendants were telling me
that he had opened his.
They'd open the door and they'd have to
help him in the car.
And then you have these little mint
candies.
He put one in his mouth and then just
fucking pointed in the right direction
and go every day.
Dude was like in his eighties.
Wow.
Probably still doing that.
Yep.
You know where it's going on right now,
the pch.
You ever go down the pch though?
The one near Malibu.
Always know the pch.
Pacific coast,
the Pacific coast highway in Malibu is a
very dangerous road.
Yeah.
And it's bar after bar,
after restaurant,
after bar,
after bar after bar.
And then all these rich people,
right,
all these people that can afford beach
houses and then people are going to
these bars and restaurants and they're
just driving.
They're driving home.
Okay.
Everyone's driving drunk.
There's just a ton of drunk driving.
The guy who did pulp fiction with
Quentin Tarantino,
the other guy who was involved with it.
What is his name?
Roger Avery.
Is that it?
Who?
He also wrote killing Zoe,
which is indirectly that I think.
Which is a fucking awesome.
Yeah,
it's a good movie.
He's a.
he's supposedly a super genius guy,
right?
Roger Avery.
Yeah.
He apparently was involved in a horrible
drunk driving accident.
Well,
Mel Gibson,
Mel Gibson incident happened right there
in Malibu.
That was at a restaurant once I saw this
guy drive off drunk.
Him and his buddies were having like a
waterfight and was hammered.
He got into his car.
They were throwing water.
Each other hammered.
Got In his car.
Yeah.
I mean the valet parking attendants need
to be responsible because they can sue
the restaurant.
Yes.
But if you're a kid and you're working
there from college and you see this
fucking guy,
like what are you going to do?
Like he's probably some rich dude.
You know,
if you,
if you get mad at him for this,
you know,
who knows how the restaurant's gonna
perceive it.
If they're going to fire,
you don't want the valleys to step in.
And some guy throwing wise sage,
most likely it's easier to like,
he'll be fine.
Just let them get in that car.
The guy's like,
that's what I would do if I was 20 years
old and I was working there like these
kids are here.
I,
I wouldn't tell this 50 year old dude
with a $10,000.
Watch on that.
He can't throw water.
He can't get in his car.
I'd be scared.
I'd be like,
sky like represents authority.
You know,
he just let him go.
I probably would let them go,
but I couldn't believe that will let
them go.
You know,
there was a bunch of people around and
people getting upset because him and the
guy with thrown water each other and
they were almost getting people so
people start getting upset,
so there was this air of tension in the
air and then the valley came and the guy
got in his car and we were like,
wow,
should we stop that?
You know,
she'd stopped that guy from getting in a
car.
It's,
it's like a judgment call.
He might have just been an idiot.
Have you ever taken someone's case?
No.
I've advised people to not drink or not
drive rather.
I've definitely done that,
but I have not taken any keys.
I haven't had to,
but I've seen some shit man.
Especially when I was young.
God,
Dallas
people drive fucked up.
Yeah.
My Dad,
I remember my mom and dad fighting about
her not wanting him to drive.
He'd be fucked up and I remember him
driving us home one night.
My mom was screaming at him before we
got in and then it was like a
terrorized,
like you,
you know that painting the scream.
That's what I looked like in the side
view mirror.
He was like going over curbs.
I was just like,
and we got home and I remember like,
uh,
he,
we were crying,
we were little kids and I remember
crying and I remember the next day he
came down to the TV room and he
apologized and then he quit drinking for
like
maybe two months.
Wow.
Yeah.
Even after two months he went back.
Hell yeah,
he would,
he would quit.
He would go through that grip of that
fucking alcoholic people,
native Americans,
you know,
right grip on them.
I haven't had it fully explained to me
because I've read it both ways.
I've read that there was some sort of a
genetic propensity towards alcoholism
that they had because the fact that
alcohol was not normal to them,
it wasn't something they had in their
diet all the time.
So they didn't have the enzymes or
whatever it was to break it down.
Well,
the liver,
the liver is different the way they.
I've heard.
That's how
real are.
Whether that's bullshit.
It's just cultural.
Yeah.
I don't know.
I don't know who's right,
it's hard,
man.
It's undeniable that certain cultures
like ours,
like the Irish,
the Italians have a lot of alcoholism.
Right?
Well,
part of it is,
I mean,
if you think about it culturally,
Italians and Irish are both Catholics.
There's a lot of repression.
There's a lot of shame and um,
you know,
when,
when that happens,
I think people act out and I think
they're,
you know,
Italians have living under fascism and
uh,
and the Catholic church,
so fucking you need to,
you need an escape,
you know,
man.
So you can,
you could drink healthy.
I see you drink Tequila sometimes.
Um,
you can handle it.
Yeah.
I can not do it.
I don't,
I could not do it for long stretches of
time.
It doesn't,
it's not something my need.
I enjoy it while it's happening,
but I understand the pole,
the biological Polish.
Some people have,
I just don't have it.
Can you get drunk sometimes?
Like real drunk.
I try not to get real drunk and the drug
has been in recent memories,
but on this podcast.
Really?
Yeah.
A couple of times.
Well,
no,
it's Chrysler for sure in the past,
but I did one recently with Hannibal
Hannibal buress.
You've got fucking lit.
We got lit to the poor and my tongue
started getting heavy.
It was hard to move around while I was
trying to entertain award.
It was like I was doing.
You ever used one of those heavy jump
ropes?
Like those jump out,
like this is ridiculous.
Like jumping rope is hard enough.
Why don't have to have this fucking ship
rope,
you know,
like the.
But they make these really heavy ones.
That's what my tongue felt like.
Yeah.
What a job.
Think about your job description.
Yeah,
it's pretty ridiculous.
Get I drank whatever.
Go for as long as you want.
Talk some shit.
So it did take a,
a,
a uber home?
Yes he did.
Yeah,
I took one here.
Took one home.
He's hilarious.
He,
yeah,
he is funny.
And we went onto another podcast right
afterwards because my friend Josh has
eps came in to do his podcast from here
with Sam Harris.
Sam Harrison is famed atheist slash
neuroscientists.
Yeah.
And Cannibal.
And Sam Harris had like this epic
argument.
Oh yeah.
Hannibal was hammered.
No Shit.
Oh,
I get to listen to that.
And I was amber do.
So I was trying to,
like,
I was trying to chime in and,
and so the whole thing was.
So it was so not good.
It wasn't like my.
Even my attempts were so clumsy.
My attempts to calm,
calm the situation down.
So embarrassing.
Yeah.
At Son Josh steps.
It hasn't come out yet.
Okay.
Is He.
I don't know what he's going to do if
he's even going to release it.
Scattered relates.
Well the problem is Hannibal didn't know
he was going to be drunk on a podcast
talking to a neuroscientist about race
issues.
Yeah.
You know,
race issues about cops shooting black
people and Statistics see the
statistics.
So I don't
know if this is accurate.
I'm just knowing what I've read and I
don't know what this means,
but I'm just going to say it.
This statistics are like,
people would think the cops are more
violently shoot more black people than
white people,
like per capita or percentage or
whatever it is.
Apparently it's not true,
so they.
They showed this,
this a study recently that shows that if
you look at the overall set,
let's find out what those numbers are so
we can talk about it and know exactly
what we're saying because this was the
argument that other white communities
experiences many shootings from cops is
black communities essentially damning
towards like what I've always said is I
think it's.
I think most people,
almost 99 percent of the people are
unqualified to be a cop.
I think it's an unbelievably difficult
job.
I think cops shoot people all the time
and they shouldn't shoot people that are
dealing with 300 million plus people in
this one continent and we're looking at
the stories of all these cops in all of
these cities and all of these counties
and all these states,
all over the country.
You're dealing with a fucking mammoth
amount of people.
Yeah.
It's just because of the history of
racism.
It's more disturbing to us to think that
there's white cops are targeting black
kids,
which they most certainly must be there.
Most certainly must be.
Some of them,
if you think of the height,
the amount of people we're talking about
there most likely is a racist or to
amongst them or or who knows how many.
Well,
there's no denying it or systemic racism
in the department.
Yeah,
but I feel like we're all on this
heightened sense of like conflict
because we're looking at the conflicts
between millions of fucking people and
we're an individual and we're taking in
these numbers,
these interactions.
Millions.
Literally millions of people interacting
with police officers every day.
It's way too much for our fucking
brains,
so we start thinking,
Jesus,
the cops are killing black people
everywhere.
Well,
turns out does it just shooting people
everywhere.
It's black people and white people.
It's just there's been some really
damning videos of them doing it to black
people and again,
there's probably a lot of cops that are
racist here,
but that's to see these stats because I
haven't heard anything like that.
This is what it was.
Washington Post they get really.
Okay.
Let's,
let's look at the actual numbers.
Were were the actual numbers.
Okay.
Post began its police shootings project
and response to the 2014 killing of
Michael Brown in Ferguson,
Missouri,
a death that triggered days of riding,
the assassination of to New York City
police officers and a surge of support
for the black lives matter,
protest movement,
Blah ba Blah ba blah ba blah ba blah.
As of January 15th,
the posted documented 987 victims of
fatal police shootings in 2015 about
twice the number historically recorded
by federal agencies.
Whites were 50 percent of those victims
and blacks were 26 percent by
comparison,
whites are 62 percent of the US
population and blacks are 13 percent.
The ensuing debate is largely centered
on whether the disproportionate
number of black deaths was a result of
police racism or the relatively high
rate of crime in black neighborhoods,
which brings black men into more
frequent and more fraught encounters
with the police.
So it seems to me just looking at those
numbers right there,
that it says whites were 50 percent of
those victims and blacks were 26
percent.
Well,
that's just right away.
There's way more white people than there
are black people,
so that seems to manage you eyes.
The blacks are twice as likely if
they're 13 percent of the population in
26 percent of the victims,
they are double a and whites are 20
percent,
so it's proportionately likely.
So this is in fact kind of like
disproving what you saying,
right?
It's saying there is a trend,
but what they're saying is,
is it sociological?
Isn't the fact that blacks were living
in dangerous neighborhoods?
The reason why there's more,
which is totally logical.
Yeah.
Well that's the argument that he should
have made.
This is not the argument he made.
That's interesting because I didn't know
that that was what the statistics were
and I wish I knew that going into that
conversation.
I've obviously had no idea we going to
have this conversation or I would've.
Huh.
That's interesting because that,
you know,
I mean you can blame it on the
neighborhood.
You get blamed on crime ridden
communities,
but if we're just going to go
statistics,
the statistic will then then they're
right.
More black people are getting shot by
cops,
but people are getting shot by cops.
Like it's a lot.
There's a lot of fucking people get 50
percent in 2015.
What is that a little about,
dude?
I don't know.
It's just terrifying.
It feels like this whole gun issue,
it didn't use to be an issue,
you know,
that the NRA used to be like a hunting
organization and people just own guns
and it wasn't a big deal and then they
made it a political issue and now I feel
like there's almost like a gun coveting.
I think there's more people that are
dangerous that are getting guns and I
think the police are probably responding
to that.
Well,
that could definitely be the case.
I mean there's a,
there's also,
when you look at guns and um,
this is one thing that I don't think we
really consider that much.
There's a gun industry,
okay.
Within their manufacturing guns
constantly and they're manufacturing
them for civilians and they can use them
legally and they can own them legally
and it's the right and people exercise
that Second Amendment right.
And they have a lot of guns and this
business keeps me guns and there's just
a lot of guns.
A lot of guns was like,
at one point in time,
we're going to have fucking guns all
over the place.
I mean the world's going to be safer
because no one's going to be shooting
people because everyone's going to have
a gun.
Because if I think of America as many
guns as there are people right now,
I think there's more.
Oh really?
Yeah,
we'll find that out because I think it
was one of those things where they were
like,
the numbers switched over.
Yeah.
They broke up the guns of out fucked
us.
Now it's going to be like,
everyone's going to have the.
What is it,
Jamie?
Jamie.
It's about the same.
Roughly twice as many guns per capita as
there were in 1968.
More than 300 million guns at all.
So it's basically the population in one
for one.
Wow.
How many of you have.
I've got a few.
Yeah,
I think about it.
You think about having one.
Well,
I feel mixed because first of all I
would feel bad as to have a gun.
I'll just say that right out there.
It would,
it would feel really fucking cool to
hold some steel and I'd have a safe and
I put it in the safe and that it would
feel good to know that if shit got
really bad that I'd be able to go out
and kill the people that have the food
in the water.
Or yourself or.
Right.
Did you ever see that movie?
The road?
Now?
I didn't see it and this is why I didn't
see it because I started watching it and
early on,
spoiler alert,
early on the movie,
He was,
uh,
talking to his kid about how to kill
yourself.
He was showing his kid how to put the
gun in your mouth if someone's coming
against you.
Really?
Yeah.
Who is,
who's The star of it?
What's that dude's name?
Handsome Fella rings.
No,
no.
To do an x files again,
our thing.
That's real,
right?
Are they?
What's his name?
Could use the work vehicle.
Baal.
He's fucking great.
He's awesome.
I'm seeing that the road.
Yeah,
I love that you have a little yellow
legal pad,
neff,
your guests,
so they can have for a while.
Yeah,
I've already got down Josh,
a Zaps and the road.
Yeah.
I wish I would,
uh,
go over these notes.
It was probably some golden there.
I write shit all the time.
I write shit all the time,
like in the middle of it.
Let's go through.
I need to remember and it never comes up
and get in there and I can barely read
my own handwriting.
It's pretty bad becoming.
It's becoming so that handwriting seems
so stupid,
like more,
more quickly.
Texting is so much better.
Well,
you know,
if this schools are deciding to stop
teaching cursive now,
which is a shame because cursive is
much,
much faster.
Yeah.
But it's goofy.
Too many people are goofy with it.
They'll give you one of these like,
what the fuck is that?
What,
what?
How the hell do I know what that word
is?
Barely made any movement.
You Lazy.
Fuck yeah.
You kind of keep sliding your hand as
you're writing.
You can't leave it there.
That's why cursive ended because people
were fucking lazy.
Lazy people would write you shit and it
was just this,
this dribble of ups and downs.
You didn't.
Was that an end?
Is it a you like a giant signature?
It looks like a fucking ekg.
It's so stupid.
It's needs to go away.
I need to know what an.
Is that an we'll make it look like in a
fuck.
You can't.
It can't be left to your interpretation
of what an a should be.
If you make a tea,
cross it where the fucking t is not it.
Don't put the eye over the L.
is there an eye over now?
Now?
Like if the dots should be above the
stem of the eye,
but there's always.
Oh,
so he's at the letter next to it.
Right.
What about like in.
Does anybody ever put the eye under the
lower k over the lower case?
J.
Did they do that anymore?
It was a door.
I make that up.
You're supposed to put it.
I like a dot over lowercase j.
yeah,
of course.
Does anybody do that?
I do.
Fuck you.
Writing something by hand.
You'd put a dot over the lowercase j.
absolutely.
I mean it's barely knew you were
supposed to do it.
Yes.
Like I had to ask.
I was questioning it.
I knew it.
I'm pretty sure that's how it would.
But I'm like,
who does that?
Yeah,
he got a deal it.
Whoa,
you're a stickler for that.
I just feel like maybe because I grew up
Catholic and penmanship was actually a
big deal.
Well,
you're actually very serious and they
might not even know you're an emmy award
winning writer.
That's right.
And that's how they give out the emmys.
They look at your penmanship.
Well,
they go all writer.
Right?
You know what I'm saying?
Yeah.
You've got to know how to put that out
there.
It's so weird when you look at Russian,
if you look at any,
uh,
like I follow a lot of Russian athletes.
I follow their instagram pages and I
looked at the rug,
Mars.
Now that might as well be from Mars.
What's up with all these fake letters?
You guys go like this jumble of how did
this happen?
Is so shitty at communicating that we
let all these different styles of
language exist to the point where none
of us can.
It's like the Tower of Babel.
What you.
We will have one language.
That's a good question man.
Look at all the weird shit they have
like that boomerang above the backwards
in like what the fight is going on up
there.
And how about the other one that looks
like a red dragons.
Like the Jason Ellis logo.
That's something there.
They have like a regular a and a regular
pig.
Well,
what the fuck?
Can we agree that these data from the
past that was in the middle on the
right.
Oh,
that's a vagina.
Vagina.
That's a very excited,
puffy one.
Yeah,
that's it.
That's a 16 year old girl.
Hey.
No,
no,
no.
It's a 19 year old girl who's 19 and
grew up in Europe.
They have a different attitude and they
clearly shave.
Yeah.
I mean how much more could have been
done a long time ago if we all spoke one
language,
the Tower of Babel Shit.
Although obviously it's great.
What's the Tower of Babel story from the
Bible?
Didn't rate it.
How dare you?
I know what I'm talking about.
A Catholic.
I am.
I was a Catholic for a year.
Um,
to the Tower of Babel is the whole thing
about it was that there's all these
different languages and that there was
some,
let's go to the actual official
definition because I'm going to fuck it
up,
but that one of the ways to keep us from
understanding each other was to give us
so many different languages.
We couldn't communicate with each other.
Right?
What does this,
what's the myth?
Find out where the meth is here.
Young tram according to the story,
a united humanity.
There it is a united humanity for the
generations following the great floods,
speaking in a single language and
migrating from the east came to the
land.
Uh,
is it going further?
Okay.
Team two came to the land of Shinara
Shin.
She say that Shannara Shannara there,
they agreed to build a city and a tower
tall enough to reach heaven.
Seeing this God confounded their speech
so that they could no longer understand
each other and scattered them around the
world.
So that's the idea of.
Well,
I mean it's basically an acknowledgement
of how much could be accomplished if we
could all speak the same language,
but we're all still like,
this is my culture man.
Like this is my culture.
This is who I'm,
you know,
I'm not abandoning this.
We all have this sense of.
It's kind of clannish like Flemish
[inaudible].
It's like this.
What is that?
A hollins?
Well,
the,
the Netherlands than Flemish Dutch speak
Dutch.
The Dutch people speak Flemish.
Oh.
Then they live in the Netherlands,
which is also called Holland with the
fuck is a lot of different names.
Yeah.
Flemish.
Yep.
Gregory's correct.
The Dutch language spoken in Flanders,
one of the two official languages of
Belgium.
Huh?
The people flenders and you know,
they have to speak three languages
because they got England next to them.
They get France next to them.
They get what?
Hold on,
Jeremy.
That was confusing.
It says it's spoken in Flanders,
one of the two official languages of
Belgium,
but that's Belgium is not Holland.
So what the fuck did we screw it up?
I think we screwed it up.
Or the Dutch.
It says it's a variety of Dutch.
Okay.
Here's another one.
Flemish also called Flemish Dutch
Belgium dust and slash or southern Dutch
refers to the varieties of the Dutch
language spoken in Flanders,
the northern part of Belgium.
The turn.
Flemish is used at least five ways.
It seems like it's all in Belgium,
man.
Yeah.
So what do people in Holland speak?
I think they speak Dutch people in
Holland that probably so mad at us now.
And fucking idiots.
We have to watch your stupid elections.
You don't even know what language we
speak.
The whole world knows that Donald Trump
and Hillary Clinton are claw each
other's eyes out to become the president
and we don't know their language.
They speak,
they speak Dutch.
And why does that one Frisians for CN
poppy?
A meadow puppy.
A mento?
Yeah.
They,
uh,
Lebanon,
South Africa and they speak Dutch there
and they've,
uh,
yeah,
they,
they fucked up South Africa,
man.
They came in hard.
Such,
it's so weird.
It's so weird when you look at like the
pockets of white people,
like when apartheid was kicking.
Yeah.
Like you look at how bizarre that
must've been like these white racist
people living in South Africa surrounded
by black people and they came over on
boats essentially.
They're like the last of one of those
colony expansion experiments.
Yeah.
They went to Africa,
right?
The British had already been there.
I think the French might've been there,
but the Dutch were the ones that came in
and just fucking dude,
turn the screws.
Imagine if there was an Africa to
Africa,
you know,
we look,
we look at Africa,
right?
And we go,
wow.
Like that's where civilization began.
Look,
there's fucking lions and people are the
Mussai warriors and running around with
spears have to kill a lion to be a man.
They're all dancing around the fire and
Tanzania and you're like,
wow,
this is a window to a totally different
world like Africa itself.
What if there was a place even fucking
crazy?
You pass Africa,
the Africans went to the dark lands and
there's just monsters tearing each other
apart,
left and right.
Nothing survived more than a few
minutes.
Everything's just fucking and killing
and it's just chaos and blaming bends in
half,
eating their babies as they come out of
the womb and bandits dressed like like
human dumpsters with machine guns
running around,
blowing each other up.
It was every things bulletproof and on
fire and then Africa is like,
I can go over to fucking cozy.
Right,
right.
Those people are looking at the Africans
and going like,
wow.
Wow.
They,
they,
they do castrations with swords.
That's actually kind of Nice.
Better than the rock we're using.
Yeah.
There's this one episode of this show
that I watched called Jim shockey's
uncharted.
He's this guy who goes to all these
different parts of the world and he's a
professional hunter and he goes to these
places and sometimes they eradicate like
dangerous animals that are threatening
villages.
Yeah,
and one of the episodes he went to this
village,
I don't remember what part of the.
Of the Congo it was,
but they have these giant saltwater
crocodiles at eight people all the time
and while they were there willing got a
no shit while they were there filming
should they took her away?
They took her out into the man number
one cause of death in Africa.
Let's rock it out.
I thought it was hippos.
Maybe you're right.
And I was making it up.
Anyway.
I think on this episode your listeners
should fact check like Flemish.
Yeah.
Number one,
cause of death in Africa.
Get back to me about.
And then the police.
We were wrong about the statistics of
police violence too,
right?
Yeah.
The,
um,
the,
the alligator crocodile things,
especially crocodiles.
Crocodiles are way,
way more,
way more aggressive in their bigger.
Some of them are.
There's the American crocodiles are
actually smaller than the American
alligators.
American crocodiles are super aggressive
though.
Their dog eaters.
Is that Florida?
Yeah.
There's a small population.
It's protected because we don't have
enough monsters and we liked him to keep
fucking because some of them you don't
understand the ecosystem.
I'm kidding.
Folks.
Relax.
I'm not,
I'm not anti crocodile,
but it is,
it's Kinda weird.
It's weird kind of.
Where do we want to keep those monsters
around?
I mean,
it's a shame because when you see what's
happening to sharks,
they kill.
I forget the numbers.
It's something like 3 million sharks a
year.
Yes,
they do.
Right,
and it's like that's fucking crate and
they're harmless animals to us.
Dislike for deaths a year in the world
from shark by.
Why am I putting all these statistics
out?
I don't think there's,
I think,
I don't think you're far off though.
Yeah,
I think we found out once,
but I don't remember what the number
was.
It was less than 25 people die every
year from sharks,
right?
Oh yeah.
Okay.
I caught up looking at a buffalo,
supposedly reportedly kill as many
people in Africa is hippos and
crocodiles.
Oh,
for sure.
Buffalo,
Cape Buffalo here.
That's huge.
Cape Buffalo Funding Shark thing.
They call them the black death.
Yeah.
Do.
They're terrifying ne running herds.
We'll look at,
look at what that looks like.
Scroll up a little bit.
Their drummer.
Yeah.
Fucking thing.
And they're super aggressive because
they're fighting off lines all the time,
man.
Yeah.
The widow maker,
credible documentary called relentless
enemies and it's about this one
particular pride of lions that lives on
an island in Africa where the rivers
changed its course and it's,
it's stranded these islands from the
rest of the rest of Africa.
These lions can't get out of this island
and all they have to eat on this island
are these giant fucking buffalo's.
Wow.
So the lines themselves have grown huge
and they become supersized lions were
females like an adult female of one of
these tribes.
There's one particular tribe where
they're enormous.
They look like the hulk,
like they don't even look like real
lions where the adult females are as
large as a regular adult male.
Other prides.
Yeah.
And so see if you find that relentless
enemy's line photos,
it's a fucking incredible documentary
because it just shows you like,
nature's going to find a way like,
oh,
all we can eat is buffalo.
Looks like we're going to have to get a
little bigger boys.
And they just got bigger.
Like the cats,
the bigger cat stayed alive.
The bigger cats figured out how to do it
and when they go after them,
look at the size of that thing that's a
female yet,
and then they're taken out these giant
buffaloes.
Yeah.
Sharp ass horns.
See if you get some photos of the
individual lions like you get.
Well there's a good good photo of it,
but just look up relentless.
Oh,
and then this was okay.
Yeah,
just a lions there.
Well,
it's,
there's some photos of a more.
They're in motion where you got to kind
of get a sense of the real mass that
they have,
but just saw one of those buffaloes
chase off a crocodile who is eating like
another species of animal.
Wow.
I don't believe that
buffaloes are enormous animals.
When you're talking about something
that's like 2000 plus pounds often.
I wonder what like the,
the biggest of the males grows too.
Have you been on safari?
No.
Real APP.
Surprised.
Scared.
Tom.
Papa was just here.
He just got back.
Oh yeah.
I just don't want to give my kids
malaria medication.
Right.
It's too young.
It's just too fucked up to require that.
And you gotta take it while you're over
there and it's just,
it's just a day,
right?
Yeah.
And then you've got to get a typhoid
shot and there's a lot on the go during
their winter.
Do you don't do it then?
Really the,
I went over there twice,
but both times it was their winter,
which is our summer.
And it was.
You don't need malaria.
No kidding.
So you didn't do anything?
Nope.
Wow.
So you have malaria?
Yep.
Okay.
Don't you see how small my look at the
head funds are practically touching that
Zika stuff,
man.
Well the big danger now is not the
mosquitoes.
It's that it's a sexually transmitted
disease and they say it's infection rate
is about the same as aids was.
Oh really?
Yeah.
Wow.
Well there's areas in Miami now where
they're thinking about like cordoning
off blocks and shit.
Right?
Why?
Because they saw mosquitoes there.
Yeah.
Because they,
they've so many cases of Zika.
Damn Dude,
it's growler too because they don't have
a vaccine and they say they're years
away from a vaccine.
So this one day there's gonna be some
insurmountable biological threat to
people.
No one day is going to be some some dark
wave that sweeps across the population
and then there's going to be a
rebuilding process.
Right?
It's just happened so many times with so
many different things too,
like it doesn't necessarily have.
And this is not something to freak out
about,
but just to put it in perspective,
there's been so many fucking times where
something's happened,
whether it's some gigantic event,
like a super volcano or diseases or just
giant chunks of the population just
died.
Yeah,
yeah.
I mean there's theories about it that
there's population control stuff that's
built in and it can manifest itself as
disease,
natural disasters or war,
but the population is kept in check.
Yeah.
I guess it just,
that's just the system that
nature runs on.
It just finds a way to exploit any
weakness.
If the numbers get too high,
there's more weaknesses.
Nature finds a way,
develops a strong attack,
and it gets in there.
It's like this little fucking Ping Pong
match game that's going on.
Constantly adjustments and then there's
medicine.
A bunch of scientists are fucking shake
in test tubes.
Find the disease all the time.
God Damn.
I mean that's pressure.
That's a long day.
I mean you think about people that work
long hours when you're a scientist
that's trying to break the code on a
fucking vaccine.
Could be,
you know,
like we would like with Ebola when they
were trying to figure something out.
Yeah.
What happened to a bola?
We got it.
Yeah,
we got it.
Like,
like the got Kadafi giving that to me.
I could have got the Kadafi video is
maybe the most disturbing video ever.
Oh no shit.
You've ever seen it now?
Oh,
do your military are in for a treat?
Military released it.
You're in for a treat.
Oh,
cell phone.
Video got released immediately.
This is what happened.
They,
the rebels overcame and the United
States backed rebels'.
Right.
I don't know the full history of how it
went down.
Do you know the full history?
I know that at one point we were a happy
back Kadafi.
Yes.
So they have Gadhafi this is him dead.
But there's video of him where they have
them and they're yelling,
allow,
walk by,
I'll walk out.
And they've got it was that him and the
rebels all have them and they're beating
the fuck out of them and they start
sticking things up his ass like swords.
They stick swords up his ass and they're
stabbing them there and see other
stabbed.
I mean they just showed a murder on TV
right there.
Yeah,
I mean back that up with that guy.
That guy is.
He was a bad.
It seems like that guy stabbing him
while he's there.
Yeah.
That was a good game of thrones killing.
I remember it was Antosz point.
Oh,
at one point because they were.
They made like a little bit about Kadafi
and people and I was like a guy shoving
a knife up his ass.
Yes.
That's the video.
So this doesn't really look where the
guy stabbing him in that picture.
And now that I looked at it again,
it looks like he's like slamming his
fist down on him.
Wow.
It's really grainy cell phone footage.
Yeah.
Well this is the one where they finally
captured them.
And they're,
they're holding up their cameras and
this is all like captured live.
I mean they have him when they have him
in there and he's freaking the fuck out
there,
pulling his hair and beating the shit
out of him.
Kicking him.
And then when he gets up,
someone sticks a sword like one of those
wastes swords,
little short swords.
Like right up his ass.
I guess it's a knife.
Big Knife.
Is that what it was?
I don't remember.
I remember thinking,
is that a stick or is that a a knife.
And then someone said it to them.
Could've put.
It's amazing.
You get these guys guys like Mugabi or
Kadafi and they do so much cruelty and
they come off as so tough.
And then he seemed like this and they
whimper and,
and bag
like little bitches.
You know,
this is really embarrassing if you think
about that,
right?
Like look at this guy and this guy was
a,
a huge dictator that ran his country for
a long time and killed a lot of people
that this is how it ends for them is
actually kind of fitting.
Right.
It's great,
I mean it happened with a Saddam
Hussein,
you know,
what is that hiding in a little cave?
It's fitting,
right,
but his neck fucked up.
It's fucked up that we liked that.
This appeals to us like that.
Look,
if they captured him the way they
captured Noriega or the way they
captured anybody else and they brought
them to trial in America and then put
them in prison,
which feel any better then him being
done to death.
Do you feel better watching this?
Like where they just locking them up?
Yeah,
really?
I do because,
and I don't believe in the death
penalty,
but in terms of how do I feel like
consciously,
I don't believe in the death penalty
because I think it's flawed.
I think the system that would execute
somebody isn't perfect.
Yeah,
I agree.
But in a case like this where,
you know,
yeah,
I think that if he's being killed by the
people that he's been subjugating,
there's something very poetic about
that.
I think there's a real problem with
cases,
you know,
whether it's a murder case or whether
it's,
uh,
any,
any kind of a case,
even like armed robbery,
a lot of,
there's,
there's a real problem when people are
competing against each other.
That's what I'm trying to get to.
When you have like a defense team that's
competing against prosecution team and
they're trying to win and you know,
you see it all the time in business
where things are inflated and there's
these crazy arguments get made.
What are they trying to do?
They trying to build up their side.
They're just not,
not try to be as objective,
as objective as possible.
Trying to go into it and say,
well,
you know,
as cops we probably could have done a
little bit better.
We probably could have been friendly as
we walked up to him and maybe they
wouldn't have gotten defensive and maybe
we could have shaken hands and go on
about our day in our lives and our paths
would have gone a different way.
But Hey,
hindsight's 20 slash 20
learning experience.
Exactly.
Learning experience.
You want
you don't.
You don't ever hear that.
It's always like one hard line.
I approach a suspect.
He was moving in a very dangerous
manner.
I saw the suspect reaching his pants.
I told him not to.
He did it again.
I at this point,
I took the safety off my weapon
discharge 32 times and you watched the
video and that's not what happened at
all.
Like someone who has cell phone on it.
Right.
That's not what happened.
That's true.
It's a weird system.
It's completely.
It's just conflict.
You know the,
the prosecutor,
your job guys are proud of the fact that
like,
I don't know if you saw that I'm making
of a murderer.
I saw some of it,
but the price water,
we'll get too involved in this.
I watched two episodes and I was like,
this is just to.
I don't want to get involved in these
people's ridiculous lives,
but he was proud of how many convictions
he'd he'd had like it was.
He was like undefeated or something in
the county,
so not rotten.
I don't smell anything right there.
And the guys in Texas that put people to
the death penalty and that's like
they're at a bar that night having a
champagne,
celebrating that he won his case and he
said,
the God of the Gas Chamber Day
put down,
put down to do.
That's what they were called it.
We'd put down.
He puts down one of the bag we put down
today.
Everybody knuckles up,
locals,
all around.
We put down today,
boy,
we've got a good one.
Good one for the good guys.
Clink,
clink,
budweisers and get sloshed.
Show for work foggy.
I'd do it again.
Put a notch in their Oxford loafers.
Well,
I mean they are dealing with a lot of
scumbags and pieces of shit and a lot of
ways.
Yeah,
but no.
Back to your point.
Their goal is not to discern the truth
and eliminate what could be done better.
It's just to kill this guy.
Yeah.
Cops don't plant evidence and try to
frame people because they're infallible
and awesome.
And that's just the right thing to do.
No,
they're.
They're.
They're doing what a dirty accountant
does.
You know,
they're doing what a joke thief does.
They're doing what a,
a guy who steals in a lot of ways now.
I love that.
You know what I mean?
Did you like when a,
when a guy steals a song,
one of the rhythms beats when they sue
people for that shit.
Yeah.
I don't know how I connected all those
together.
I really had a point until you started
laughing.
I started it suck.
It's something,
you know,
and they,
they,
they suck at,
uh,
you know,
the gigantic responsibility that comes
with being a police officer.
Yeah,
there's not,
they're not really qualified for that.
It's a politician.
Each one is a politician.
They're supposed to be on the ground
interacting with people,
making connections,
getting people to trust them,
getting people to follow their lead.
You know,
like you read,
I read about this one lapd guy and he
started a football team and it was a
police football team and nobody would
join because the community was so
opposed to the cops that literally they
were like,
we got uniforms,
we got helmets,
we got fields,
we get coaches.
We want to have a team.
You guys can play against other city
teams.
Nobody.
And then this one guy started,
he was a former player cop now and he
reached out and slowly got one kid,
two kids finally get up to 11 kids,
started training him,
got to know the parents,
the other,
the other cops were helping out
training,
got to know the parents and it opened up
this whole community.
It changed the caves in south central.
Somewhere in the whole neighborhood is,
has a great relationship with the cops
now.
Wow.
Yeah.
It can be done right?
It can be done.
This just got to be away.
If you,
if you look at the overall picture,
it's got to be a way to do it better
than they're doing it right now across
the board.
Everything was like managing
communities.
Like it just,
it just seems like there's so much room
for improvement.
Yeah.
You know,
Obama just released 111 prisoners and I
think that the message that he's sending
is like,
we got to get over this police state
mentality
release.
One guy that,
uh,
had retweeted a petition to release him
like a year ago.
Yeah.
He was,
um,
in jail for life,
for selling lsd.
How would a grateful dead concert?
Yeah.
I ran and Obama exonerated him.
He's never should've gone to jail in the
first.
Well,
it was his third strike.
That's why I went.
But they got to get rid of that third
strike thing.
Yes.
And also when you do as much acid as
that guy does,
he think he remembers those first two
strikes I made up.
That three strikes thing is crazy.
It's so crazy.
I'm not for,
you know,
encouraging people to continue fucking
up.
But the thing that,
the only way,
like if someone does three petty crimes,
I mean how many,
how bad is the crime after be?
Does it have to be a violent crime
before your three?
I'm not sure.
That doesn't make sense with the
grateful dead thing.
Unless somehow know that they think of
selling drugs,
they find some sneaky way to categorize
that as violence.
Yeah.
Maybe if it's a,
what do they call it?
Level one drug or assets.
Probably like the highest level of
drugs,
so maybe that's a felony,
whereas pot would be a misdemeanor.
Hmm.
Yeah.
Right.
I would wonder.
It doesn't sound like the other charges
were violent.
I think all three were drug related.
Listen,
the thing about acid that you can get a
whole lot of it in a very small,
like packaged.
Sure.
Like you can get a whole lot of hits and
you can carry it on you.
It's like books of stamps.
Yeah.
And that's a lot of people are getting
fucked up off that.
Yeah.
So I think that's problematic to people.
I think to get super nervous about that.
Mckenna had some speech he did about
that once about how someone in a regular
apartment with a bathtub can make enough
acid to get a million people blasted.
No Shit.
Wow.
Think of the quality control there.
One guy's getting triple the amount of
another guy.
This is another great analogy that
someone said or wish I remember who,
but they said that acid,
like in the molecule form the molecular
form,
it's,
it's so potent.
It is literally like watching an ant
dissolve,
the empire state building,
like something as small as an aunt or
build or dissolve or take like you're
talking about.
I should probably know if it's built to
dissolve,
right?
Thing might be built,
but the idea being that there's so much
power in such a small molecule,
it's such a small,
amazing that you need the tiniest dose.
Like a blip.
Yeah,
and you're fucking crazy.
I talked to a dude who did 25 hits of
acid in one setting.
No Shit.
Fuck them up.
I don't know.
I don't know what he was like before
then.
Yeah,
seemed okay.
I knew a couple of guys.
It changed.
Changed.
Yeah.
Just lost their edge man.
You know,
just had that kind of slightly vacant
stare all the time.
That's why I never took acid.
I've taken everything,
but I've never taken acid.
It definitely seems like it has a
potential to do that and I think some
people just go super deep man.
Right.
What is this?
Oh,
okay.
Here it is.
I'm following algae on a molecular
level.
The power of LSD is equivalent to a fire
ant that can completely tear down the
empire state building and under 30
minutes.
Yeah,
so that's what it was.
I was the first time.
Jesus.
How crazy is that?
A fire ant that could take down the
empire state building in 30 minutes.
What is it?
How do they make it?
Just a really good question and I don't
know the answer to that.
I know who figured it out and you know
the story of Albert Hoffman.
The guy was a creating.
I think he was trying to come up with a
women's fertility drug.
I believe that was the original thing.
I think so if I remember correctly and
that's where it came from,
but then they used it for all different
kinds of successfully on his hands.
Like,
dude,
he was the Guinea pig.
He got on his hands in the lab.
He didn't know what the fuck he was
touching.
Yeah,
Guy knew his skin through his hands.
Pretty sure that's the story.
And he went riding home on his bike
tour,
happen his balls off,
thinking about the world in a whole new
way of looking at life in a whole
different way and going,
wow,
that's where I asked her,
was born.
And then he went back to it and he did a
bunch of different experience
experiments with it.
Oh yeah.
I mean Ucla,
Columbia University,
like some that didn't go.
So good.
Berkeley.
Yeah.
Well,
yeah.
But I think some of those were staged by
the government.
Do you know who was involved in one of
the,
uh,
Harvard asset studies?
Harvard?
Yeah.
A Timothy leary.
Ted Kaczynski.
No Shit.
Yeah.
Wow.
Ted Kaczynski was a part of one of those
assets studies.
They blew that guy's Bahrainis out.
And then he went to Berkeley and worked
as a professor for a short period of
time just to get enough money to
implement his manifesto to move into
that cabin in the woods and start
killing people who are creating
technology now.
He Won.
He lost his fucking mind.
He really did.
I mean,
he might've been crazy before that.
Who knows.
But you know the story about the
unibomber that his brother recognize the
manifesto as his own brothers kind of
fucking crazy writing of.
That's how we get caught.
Yeah.
Wow.
His brother recognize the patterns and
you recognize that the person writing it
had to be very smart and also very
crazy.
What a moment to think.
I've got to turn my brother and he was
probably terrified at this brother that
was capable of killing people.
I wonder if he knew it before then when
your brother just moved to the woods in
a shack.
Starts writing things with no spaces.
Cursive.
Yeah.
Just book after book.
I need another notebook.
Oh,
Jesus Christ.
Are you writing?
I'm writing everything.
Writing everything.
Documented it all.
Everything that's wrong.
How to make it.
You think assets done more good or more
bad?
Overall?
It's probably more good,
but there's always gonna be room like
booze.
When we were talking about booze,
some people can enjoy a glass of wine
and not have another drink for a month
and everyone's fine.
Some people it's one shot and they're
off to the races.
One shot goes down the hole.
Does the lids come down over the eye?
Clank.
Clank that does drunk Lids,
you know,
we'd be like,
where's Greg?
Greg in there.
I never seen you drunk because when I
met you,
is rick right when you were quitting?
Yeah.
But uh,
my mom tries to get me drunk and
Adelaide,
she pulled out some limited Shalla,
you know,
that lemon liqour in Italy and she
fucking poor a shot for all of us,
including my 13 year old daughter.
And my mom is crazy.
You know me.
Well,
I told you about my father.
You think she'd have some awareness?
She can't stand the fact that I quit
drinking.
Why don't you just telling me a story
about your mom and gambling?
She's a gambler who told me crazy
casinos.
Sorry.
Well she goes,
she plays poker two different nights a
week with all guys and she does good.
And so she,
uh,
she,
her and her sister go and they go to
these slot machines in yonkers and they
go down there and uh,
my aunt goes,
she's got more of a problem than my
mother and she wins a flat screen TV.
But her husband doesn't know that she
gambled.
She's forbidden to gamble because she's
got this problem.
So he's home one day and a guy knocks at
the door and he's like,
we got to delivery.
It's like,
what is,
he goes a 62 inch TV.
Where do you want.
He's like,
W,
we didn't order a TV.
No,
no,
you want it.
What do you mean we want it at the,
at the yonkers raceway Kasina you won
this.
So she had to come home and explain to
her husband why there was a flat screen
tv she wanted on the slots.
It was like the grand prize.
Oh,
that's hilarious.
And then she got run down one time by a
guy who would just,
one,
broke her hip in the,
uh,
in the aisle.
But of the slots.
Whoa.
Wrong place the wrong time.
Guy One got excited.
Just ran a over ran.
Just ran down the yelling.
The screaming.
Yeah.
And just smashed into the ground.
Smashed to the ground.
She was in a wheelchair.
You know,
it's all gambling.
God Damn.
Yeah.
How did that get resolved?
Oh God,
I don't know.
I wonder if there was a lawsuit.
Well,
it's like for him it's like I win all
this money and then it's gone.
Right?
Yeah.
Like right there in one movement,
she's going to sue him for sure.
He said,
just give me the bag.
Let's walk away.
Do you think she sued him?
I don't know.
I mean,
it doesn't seem like her nature to sue,
but at the same time the insurance
company might make her.
Because once you get medical bills,
your insurance company immediately goes,
well,
we're not paying these.
You've got to sue the other person.
Right,
right,
right.
Yeah,
man.
Yeah.
If your dog bites somebody,
you're going to get sued by their
insurance company.
Wow.
Yeah,
totally makes sense.
But a guy running over you like that.
That's.
It's so awful,
man.
You're an older woman and some big
fucking stupid dude runs you over.
Oh fuck man.
And it's one thing if you're like a,
you know,
maybe you were,
you were helping out down at the
homeless shelter.
Somebody ran you over your gambling.
He does work in the fucking the one arm
bandit.
Yeah.
What the fuck man.
Yeah,
I don't gamble anymore.
It's just,
it's just so predictable.
Yes.
If you look,
if you look an hour down the line,
it's predictable,
but feel 10 minutes down the line.
It's exciting.
Well,
it's a little.
It's a little drug dispensary.
Yeah.
You know,
you're getting your highs and your lows.
You're getting your anticipation.
You're going to get your reward.
You're going to get you defeat.
God.
Damn.
You going to be frustrated.
You want to smoke all the ladies coming
over the booze.
Yeah,
double we please.
Thank you.
Thanks.
It's you're getting one stroke of your
Dick every like three minutes.
Not a full hand.
I've just a soft stroke down,
pulling the foreskin over the crown.
Just a little bit issue.
She releases and then she walks away for
three minutes,
comes back and then you got this weird
relationship with this dealer,
dude.
Yeah.
Well this guy is either given you money
or taking money away from you,
and he's like,
Hey,
it's just my job.
That's my job.
Yeah.
He touches money all day and they barely
pay him.
The guy's making.
He's making 15 bucks an hour and he's
dealing with thousands of dollars.
How much do they make?
I think it's a union gig.
They get tips,
right?
That's a big part.
I don't know if they pull tips.
I think they probably pull their tips.
They pool them all the people together.
That doesn't make sense.
That would seem like.
Does that make sense?
Is that how they do it?
If you're one of the eight people
working in an hour or whatever during
your shift,
however they do it and you're at the hot
table and your table makes $25,000
in tips just because you circumstances
were there just because of the.
The like the schedule,
the routine.
Just a shift cycle.
Now you made a year's money and
everybody else you're working with guys
zero.
They're all gonna.
Be pissed at you.
And how long have you been a communist?
I'm just saying I have a friend that did
it and Columbus side.
Now that's how it works,
so they shouldn't try.
Shouldn't try.
They shouldn't be charming,
but no,
it totally makes sense.
Some of them just,
you know,
they're so over it and you can tell it's
like a typical union.
Jack and I love unions.
I'm all about fixing the fucking unions.
I know there were a problem.
I know they don't work,
but like you see that it's like a flight
attendant or a dealer.
When they're over it,
it's like you gotta just put them out to
pasture.
He can't keep them working in your
business.
When they don't smile,
they don't.
Their
energy is negative.
Get them the fuck out.
It's bad for business.
Yeah,
it's man.
What can you do though?
Well,
it's seniority.
That's the problem.
You're getting the oldest,
most tired people
working.
Let.
That's why I like a new airline.
You know?
You got a virgin.
Virgins Gray.
Yeah.
They got hot,
young,
beautiful flight attendants.
After a while.
People just don't want to work anymore.
Man.
I think people work too much.
I think they work too long.
You know?
I think that's part of the problem.
When did you become a communist?
Today?
Right after Jamie and made sense.
Jamie made sense with the tips.
I'm like,
he's right.
I don't stick to my ideas.
Folks call it flip flopping.
I'm not married to these motherfuckers.
Well,
that's why this is,
you know,
this is an open dialogue.
We're here to change and grow.
Yes.
Trying to change and grow.
Trying to learn some information or what
a great fucking.
I've talked about this yesterday,
but Neil degrasse Tyson had this great
twitter quote that said there should be
an option in this presidential election
for an all presidential elections,
I think you said for none of the above,
and then if none of the above wins,
we have to start all over again with new
people like it.
That would definitely be the case this
time.
That's actually a really good idea.
Yeah,
that's a really good idea.
Yeah.
Well,
none of the above requires a
congressional reexamination of the
election process and the potential
candidates and what makes them
qualified.
Yep.
We do it live on television.
There's long discussions like for days
and days and days,
like on Cspan,
you know,
remember those you ever watch cspan just
watched people argue about shit.
Now you're watch that.
That's interesting.
Yeah.
It's interesting to see how the courts
work and everything so formal and I
guess you have to have like these really
clear rules when you're all talking.
The gentleman has five minutes to
address when you ever have anything
formal.
Well,
they said it has rules because when it
was first created,
it was the southerners and they were
genteel.
So to this day when I'm talking to
another member,
you never say you.
You're not allowed to say you to
somebody.
You say the d senior,
the senior senator from Wisconsin?
Yes.
Said,
uh,
you know.
Yes.
And they say if you want to insult
somebody,
you're not allowed to,
but you can say my most learned esteemed
colleague from Massachusetts,
which is a way of shitting on the guy.
Really?
Yeah.
Oh,
that's what they have to talk third
person about it.
Wow.
Those are bizarre rules,
Huh?
Yeah.
Do you know what's really kind of sad
but fascinating at the same time,
she knew who was really good at those
speeches.
Dom irrera.
Anthony Wiener.
Oh the best.
He was a politician.
He liked his policies much of a freak.
Well,
good looking guy.
You gotta put that shit out there.
Things could look now.
No,
not really.
No.
Which makes me respect them even more.
For some reason.
He.
He's a fascinating character because I
almost think like,
to be that kind of firebrand,
you've almost got to be Horny,
right?
You know,
just like a rally the troops,
like everybody,
like he,
he would get like super passionate and
they give really good speeches.
Yup.
It's like God damn.
And I remember people thinking like,
this motherfucker is a real politician.
I don't trust a politician that's not
fucking somebody on the side.
Let me hear this
in a minute,
but we're still a no.
And then we stand up and start.
Boom.
We had a different process.
We vote yes.
If you vote yes.
If you believe yes,
your vote in favor of funding you to
believe it's the right thing.
If you believe it's the wrong thing,
you know we are following up with your
regular order,
regular order to get to intimidate
people into bleeding.
He's right.
He is.
The gentleman is wrong.
Rather than doing the right thing,
it's Republicans wrapping her arms
around Republicans rather than doing the
right thing on behalf of the heroes.
It is a shame.
Shame if you believe this is a bad idea
to provide healthcare view.
That was a different procedure.
The gentlemen will absorb regular order.
I'd say he's a bad motherfucker.
The only thing missing is fucking.
He's a bad motherfucker fucking in
between every phrase because that's what
he's saying.
He's going to sit the fuck down there.
He's just too crazy.
Yay.
I love that.
Yeah,
you're right.
You know,
this is a fiery guy.
Fiery horny.
Passionate.
Oh,
look at the JFK Johnson and Clinton.
I would argue that he's,
you've never see a politician that has
that level of emotion that's incredibly
rare.
So like what he's doing,
there's very theatrical.
Yup.
Which is what they've always said that
like politicians are just ugly actors.
Yeah.
You know,
like it's like show business for people.
Weren't that good looking?
Yeah.
I mean it's kind of in a way what it is
and they don't really have a talent.
Although Bill Clinton did play the Sax
Saxophone.
Remember that?
Yeah,
but that was before he was president,
right?
Wasn't it when he went on to senior hall
now running?
Well,
I think he was.
Oh,
he was running.
That's right.
Because they say it got into the black
vote.
Yeah.
Listen,
another one,
he's another perfect example.
Just buzzy.
Yep.
And he was an animal.
That's why these people are doing,
but that's why they want to be a leader.
It's almost like we want to deny our
very nature.
We almost want to pretend that people
like that,
like these crazy fiery people that get
everybody rallied up that there's not
other things that go with that package.
Right.
Of course he's.
But he's,
he's went of course weight over the top.
Yeah.
Took pictures of his kid next to his
dick.
Did you see that to the girl can
weird.
He's weird.
He's got a.
he's definitely sad for the wife because
he just,
you know,
she forgave him.
She took him back.
He said he was going to go to these
classes and do all that shit and then.
And then,
you know,
it's humiliating the first time.
It's pitiful.
The second.
Yeah.
It's hard out there for a pimp.
Shit,
you know?
Yeah.
I'm sure it is.
I'm sure it is a humiliating.
I'm sure it is a.
I mean it's just the whole thing is
crazy in the first place that he has
this compulsion to just chat with girls
online like that,
send Dick pics and stuff like.
It's like for him it's like so fun.
It's obviously so fun and it's beyond
insane.
His last name,
his wiener.
It's hilarious.
Yeah,
it's,
it's almost like we're living in a movie
at this was in a judd apatow movie.
He'd be like,
why is so obvious?
Name is weening of my 13.
You know?
Dick Wiener was so weird.
Yeah.
People are weird,
man.
People are fucking weird.
They're so weird.
Well,
if you want to be that bad,
I mean it's kind of a thing in life is
like how passionate do you allow
yourself to be?
Because there's a loss of control that
that goes with getting that passionate
and when you,
when you go for it,
that's when you end up,
you know,
maybe having an affair or maybe killing
somebody because you're just fucking
letting your id run wild.
But that's where sometimes great
creativity comes from,
which is why you get so many great
artists and directors that ended up,
you know,
woody Allen [inaudible] and his daughter
and you know,
a Roman Polanski,
like,
you know,
you just think of all the truly creative
people,
they do fucked up things because they're
just putting themselves out there.
Well also because a lot of what makes
them want to be whatever it is in the
first place,
whether it's an actor or a famous person
or a singer or Kelly or any people like
to want to be out there that much.
Yeah.
The Ego.
There's some,
some.
It's got to be some,
some madness involved in that.
Yeah.
Usually.
And a lot of it involves like your
childhood and how you're wired growing
up or what,
what you were missing that led you to
push so hard.
Yeah.
Like everybody that I know,
you included.
That's hilarious.
Had some crazy fucking life growing up.
Yeah.
You know where it was like,
you know when you tell me the story
about your parents chain smoking in the
house while you were just locked in the
winter with the windows closed and
you're like a baby.
I'm going,
I had asthma inhaler.
Fucking quit smoking in front of.
In the car with your kid who has an
asthma inhaler in his pocket.
No,
I can't.
Fuck.
We used to give them for presence here.
Do you remember this?
In Art Class?
You'd get shells and you'd paint the
shells.
Like little clam shells.
You ever do that?
And you paint them.
You glaze them and bake them.
And then we give given to my parents and
they've used them as ashtrays.
Oh my God.
It's like putting a cigarette out in
your little heart.
Here's what I think of those three
hours.
You spend the art class too.
That's a pole.
That's an undeniable one,
right?
Smoke cigarette one.
That seems like everybody gets that one.
Like the alcohol pole.
It's like some people get it,
some people don't.
Some people can drink a little and not
drink for awhile.
Cigarettes.
It seems like almost everybody who gets
into it gets stuck.
Yeah.
It seems like it's like if you were
looking at it as a Jujitsu artists,
it's got a very high rate of finishes.
Yeah.
Like there's certain guys that get into
certain positions,
like you might be fucked.
Like,
uh,
there's this Guy Damien Maia fights in
the UFC strangles everybody and he's
just one of those guys when he gets on
your back,
you're like,
Ooh,
you're.
You probably fucked.
Yeah.
He's the,
he's got a very high rate of finishing
and that's like if you're smoking
cigarettes for three months,
get Tina headline smoking cigarettes
everyday for three months.
Come on.
Let's be honest.
No,
it's chemical.
Yeah.
I mean they say they say that it's tough
for them to.
Heroin Addiction.
I can imagine.
A really good.
I really could imagine.
I've heard people argue back and forth
about the heroin thing.
I had this Guy Dr Carl Hart on my
podcast and it was actually being
discussed recently on the message board,
which is why I'm bringing it up where
they were.
There were saying that he's not correct
about because he says he's actually
experimented with a bunch of drugs
himself,
is pretty open about it,
but he's also a like a brilliant
academic writes books.
He's an addiction specialist and he's
like,
there's so much misinformation when it
comes to heroin withdrawal.
He goes,
it's like being sick.
It's like you have the flu.
Yeah.
That's literally what it's like.
He's like,
that's the physical embodiment of all
the symptoms.
They're very flu like and then they go
away.
Yeah.
He's like,
there's more.
It's more psychological and there's.
There's so much more going on about
this,
like sort of dependency on this
substance.
It's not just like a physical
dependency,
like there's a bunch of other factors
that sort of can't be denied or ignored
and they all play in together,
but then other people on my message what
we're saying,
no,
you're wrong.
Like tried to kick heroin.
It was unbelievably hard on my body was
in shock and then then another dude who
said that all he did was get on a plane
and go somewhere where he knew he
couldn't get heroin for a while and
that's how he kicked it.
He said,
fuck it,
I'm just not going to do this anymore.
And he said it was only like a few days
of feeling like a flu.
I don't know who the fuck is.
Right?
And I also don't know.
Again,
if it's the same for everybody,
it's like the alcohol thing,
all these different things.
Totally.
Some people have addictive behaviors,
personalities,
but I think the problem is is just
because you kicked the drug,
you're now back to square one and square
one was I need drugs.
You may not be addicted,
but you still didn't do the work
necessary to rebuild your foundation and
to have dependency issues.
So now you're at a weakened state
because you've just had the flu and you
need to start going to meetings,
being disciplined,
you know,
go whatever it takes to,
if it's talk therapy or exercise,
whatever it is and makes you write,
you need to transition into that
immediately.
And most people,
well don't,
you know,
had you ever smoke.
I smoked a cigarette or two with my
sister when I was 15 and she was 14.
We moved into this new neighborhood and
hung out with the local tufts.
Hey Joey.
And we went to the bridge.
We went down to the bridge.
There's this place near my house called
Eco Bridge.
It was actually right across the street
from my house when I was growing up.
And uh,
you could get under the bridge and you
could yell and it echoes in this crazy
way.
It's in Newton,
upper falls,
Massachusetts.
And um,
we'd go down there and sing billy squire
song.
What did you find yourself alone?
And it was all,
you know,
at people feeling each other up and
drinking beers.
I snuck out of their dads kitchen the
best times of your life.
Very strange times,
man,
very strange times.
It doesn't get much better than that,
sadly.
Well,
it was a,
it was all very interesting.
And then,
um,
there was a kid who was a little bit
older than us that we knew that we were
hanging out.
That's it.
It's right by the Charles River.
That's where I grew up.
Q and a good job today.
Jamie's done the ball son.
Um,
but there's a kid who was in my
neighborhood who killed somebody drunk
driving and killed his best friend while
we were all in high school together.
Leaving Echo Bridge.
No,
no,
no.
But it was that kind of thing,
you know,
it was like everybody was partying.
People are going,
that's all anybody wanted it to do.
So everybody's going to parties.
You know,
Mike,
he's having a party this weekend.
You go and dog,
he's got a party.
We're gonna go,
hey,
we got to find a place to party.
And there was.
This is like the cave caveman days.
Yeah.
We're talking about like the 19 eighties
people were cavemen.
No one had phones.
There was no,
there was.
Most people didn't even have fucking
answering machine.
Yeah,
no basic cable.
You had like three channels.
Yep.
So,
uh,
people would just wind up getting drunk
and they were kids and a lot of them
drove home drunk and I tried really hard
not to,
but I'm sure it probably did it at least
two or three times on when I was a
teenager.
I drove to the point where I definitely
shouldn't have been driving.
Oh,
I drunk drove fucking three nights a
week,
like severely drunk.
It was crazy.
Yeah.
Well Luckily I wasn't drinking that much
because it was like,
right when I just started transitioning
to getting into martial arts and from
then on I pretty much stopped partying.
Totally.
But it coincided with this dude around
the same time.
Um,
I'm not sure like numbers wise,
I might be off by a year or two,
but it was around that area where I was
realizing that there was a lot of us.
They were like doing a really
irresponsible,
dangerous shit,
like driving drunk and being drunk all
the time.
Going to these parties and having fun.
And I'm like,
this is like someone's going to drown so
it's going to fall off a roof,
some shit's going to go down.
And then this dude,
I guess he hit a tree or something like
that and killed his best friend.
Did he survive?
He survived,
you know,
what a thing to live with.
And we were all like,
oh shit.
The cops actually broke it to them that
way.
You killed your best friend.
Like that's what they said when he was
coming out of the unconsciousness in the
hospital.
That's how they explained it to him.
You killed your restaurant.
Like what?
Jesus just probably blitzed,
you know.
And also probably if I had a guess,
I think he was a little older than me.
I might've been like 17 at the time,
so he was 18,
18 and it's done.
It's over kid,
maybe I,
maybe I have it wrong.
16 and 17.
But it was somewhere in that range of.
He's a young guy who was just starting
to drive and now all of a sudden his
friend's dad and he's got that mark on
him for the rest of his life.
And I remember thinking,
alright,
fuck drinking,
fuck all this fuck pot.
I didn't want to have nothing to do with
anything,
anything that was going to ruin my life.
And like you can really ruin your life
and other people's lives and the loved
ones with those other people.
Yeah.
Lot of narrow escapes.
I think about the situations.
It's true.
There's a ripple effect.
You can change whole communities with
one action.
Yup.
If I had a buddy growing up and he was a
bad alcoholic ice to take an AA meetings
and people try to do interventions and
he was just really,
really chemically bad.
He was Jacqueline Hyde personality,
you know,
he when,
when he was sober,
he was the greatest guy in the world.
Loved hanging out with them and he gets
drunk and he tried to fight me.
I was crazy.
And so one night he was driving,
he had his girlfriend in the car and
they got into a fight.
And so like he left her,
she got out of the car and then he got
on the highway,
but then he stopped to go back and get
her.
So we got back on the highway going the
opposite direction and hit a car head on
and killed the two people and died.
Oh.
And it was like the town still.
It's like his family is so intertwined
in my town,
um,
that it was like a,
almost like a political party there.
So,
you know,
part of it will.
You think about Ted Kennedy,
Ted Kennedy Day.
I keep bringing them up,
but uh,
that chappaquiddick thing.
Chappaquiddick bridge where he was drunk
and his car went into the water and his
girlfriend drowned.
Yeah.
And he didn't report it until hours
later.
Next morning.
Yeah.
And end it with him.
I got the sense that he'd been driving
drunk every fucking night.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
Competing ski.
You don't get that face.
Mary Jo.
Yeah,
man.
We always remember that when we were
kids.
There it is.
He just fucking left later.
Wow.
It's so dark.
I wonder if you could have saved her.
I just went off the bridge.
Drunk as fuck off the bridge.
She drowns.
That's something he had to carry with
him,
right?
Or not.
Some people carry stuff more than
others.
I mean he continued to drink.
That wasn't his bottom out point,
you know,
who might've drank to forget.
Yeah.
Something like that.
He had a lot to forget.
He had two brothers that were
assassinated.
The one who died flying a plane in world
war two or you know,
joe and he lived to see his nephew.
A Di flying his plane.
Remember that?
Yeah.
That was another weird one.
It was a weird judged the ocean.
Yeah.
I.
was he fully licensed at the time?
I don't know.
I think he might've been,
but he should've had more hours.
For what?
At what time of night?
He was flying in the distance or
something.
It wasn't a flying and fog as well.
Yeah.
Holy Shit.
His wife was a friend of mine from Bu.
Carolyn bessette.
Yeah.
We were friends with her.
Holy Shit.
Second most beautiful woman I've ever
seen in my life.
Other than your wife.
Thank you.
Well done.
Thanks.
I liked how you did this gorgeous woman
like lit up a party.
Green Eyes Tall.
Just sucking,
striking.
Fuck.
Flying your own plane,
Bro.
I don't know,
I mean it feels like it might be a lot
of fucking fun.
I've never done it.
I have been in other people's plans.
Yeah.
When I was in high school,
uh,
I had a kid who was real good friends
with one of those,
like 14 and his dad wasn't even 14.
Why am I rambling?
His uh,
his dad was like a big time hunter and
fisherman and he would fly around and
actually I think it was a poacher in
fact.
Oh yeah.
I think he had,
he was missing an eye because he was a
very strange guy.
Yeah.
And uh,
we would go camping with this dude and
he would be outside in Maine and it was
like zero degrees out.
He'd be out there in his underwear and
as long underwear didn't give a fuck.
So he had ice water in his veins and be
so cold out.
And this guy just standing around
talking to people with the tee shirt on.
He just didn't give a fuck he fat yet.
Yeah.
Bitch,
tits fat gut only fat people that stand
out in the cold like that.
He wasn't like an old school,
sort of a survivor type dude in a lot of
ways.
Like he was,
he was a guy who could like stay in the
woods and like live in the woods and he
had a plane,
one of those little,
one
of those little shitty prop planes.
Yeah.
And uh,
like you'd see on one of those,
uh,
mountain men episodes with the guys are
flying over the woods by themselves.
Yeah.
He had one of those.
And uh,
his son was learning how to take
lessons.
I went up with him,
so we were like,
you know,
we were fucking kids,
like really young and he's flying around
this God damn airplane with a,
with an instructor but me,
him and an instructor because it's
scary.
Oh yeah.
Like this thing's a piece of shit.
Yeah.
I mean this is like a Bush plane.
It's like barely held together.
It's like,
it's like a lot of people's cars,
you know,
you get into some people's
cars,
you're like,
all right,
I hope we make it,
you know.
And in that case,
maybe a coast onto the shoulder if
things don't go well,
like if you were friends with a comic
and uh,
they uh,
give you a ride and like,
hey,
you go into the Improv.
Can I go with you?
Yeah,
sure.
And you get into cards and 86 buick you
like,
we might not make it there guys.
We're moving along.
We've got to really.
This might not work out.
I kinda miss that feeling.
Do you know I had aaa and I fucking used
it.
Yeah.
I think you get three pickups a year and
I just always remember going over my
three,
my three ride maximum.
I'll tell you
this,
I do think that the character building
aspects of driving and a place where
your car could break down or get stuck
in the snow and the ice that we
experienced when we were kids.
I think there is something that I really
benefited from that I've benefited from
being scared of the weather for awhile.
Like an understanding like,
okay,
if you drive out there tonight,
there's fucking four inches of snow on
the ground.
They haven't done any plowing.
You're going to run into some black eyes
too,
because you know it was raining before
it was snowing for.
Got Cold enough to snow.
Okay,
we're going to do this like nobody.
Nobody has to do that for now.
There's no.
You don't ever have to go out and wonder
whether or not you're going to stay on
the road.
Yeah.
I think that was a real issue when we
were kids.
Couldn't.
Can You keep your car on the road
whether you put chains on it.
I never did change.
Did you change?
When I was in Boston,
I did some gigs.
Values changed going up to a that hotel,
the balsams hotel.
I don't think they would
booked you.
Is that the one where they could see you
were swearing?
They kicked you out and made you drive
home with a moose were on the road.
I drove four and a half hours up to
Maine to go to this fucking hotel and
they tell you it's a nice.
It's like the nicest hotel in New
England.
It's like it's 150 years old.
It's like the shining.
It's huge and I drive up there like four
and a half hours and um,
I get there and they go,
all right,
listen to 20 minutes and just please
don't say fuck.
So I walk on stage and I go,
well they told me I can't say fuck
tonight.
So,
and I say fuck about 10 times and I,
I had checked into my room and unpacked
my bag was packed and they like,
you're out of here and now it's midnight
and I mean,
you know,
main black out at night.
I mean there is no fucking light at all.
And just moose deer,
fucking constant wildlife on this little
two lane road for hours.
Oh my God.
Yeah.
It was brutal.
That road from like,
is it Portland to Bangor?
Is that.
What's the first stop when you go across
the border in the main?
Um,
I think it's a,
Portland's the most close city one
that's a little bit closer.
I'm Kenneth know something bridge.
Okay.
Yeah.
But anyway,
we would go across that and then you
would go from this one stop all the way
to Bangor.
It was one exit and it was
60 miles.
Who was a long stretch.
Yeah,
it's probably like 60 miles.
Right?
I'm not exaggerating,
am I?
I don't think I am now.
We didn't think about that with those
gigs.
We never think thought about how far was
we just thought about date to write in
my calendar.
That's it.
You got a date?
I got an open.
I'm fucking there.
I don't care where it is.
No hope.
Never a hotel.
That Balsam's thing was like the only
Gig you got that we stayed in a hotel.
Right?
I did a few for.
There was a couple people that booked
gigs.
Oh,
it was normal.
A.
Oh and Sherry and Sherry.
Her shares to have a bunch of them put
normal.
The forehead one,
I believe it was in Maine and it was
actually like a pretty good gig.
Yeah.
And then a member like there was so many
people that book gigs like build downs
was booking gigs,
the comedy connection,
the old comedy connections book and a
Boston comedy was booking Mary cats.
Yeah.
There was a lot of different people that
realized like digged,
already booked a lot of gigs.
Yeah.
They'd realize that they can make money
just by setting up these comedy nights
in these bars and so we would travel all
over New England doing these things with
some of those gigs,
like the Bangor one would take you to
these places where if you weren't a
comedian,
what are the odds you're just going to
go drive up there one day you're going
to leave Boston and take a three and a
half hour drive up through the
wilderness and there's little tiny ass
roads in January.
I know and we had no fucking GPS.
We had a map and a prayer,
you know,
and,
and it was like,
you know,
you never knew if you booked the Gig.
If it was more than three months out,
there was a 50 percent chance to Gig was
cancelled.
I never booked anything that far out.
I don't think now I wasn't that
desirable.
I was getting gigs.
You were the filling guy?
Yeah,
I was getting.
If I got a good Gig,
it was like,
you know,
two weeks out or something like that,
but there was the gigs that were like
the fucking death gigs at death get
giggles.
I know they loved you early on.
Right.
Didn't they use the headline you early
on?
That was my Clark giggles is Mike Clark
and Mike Clarke.
Like it was like a kid.
Yeah,
you gotta you gotta clean it up.
Rogan.
Yeah,
he was up.
It was really funny.
Like it was one of the Clark's brother
by the was dirty and one of the best
comics from Boston ever.
Like Lenny Clarke is a monster and just
dirty partier,
you know,
just an animal.
Right.
They used to do cocaine every night for
a decade at least.
Yeah.
The second time I ever got paid to work,
I worked for normal a foe and I worked
at Jay's and Pittsfield.
Pittsfield.
Pittsfield is another place you drive
way out there.
And um,
uh,
I got offstage,
I opened for Lenny,
I got offstage and Mike was like,
look,
I'd like to use you,
but you got to clean it up.
And those fucking Madonna bit.
I mean it was funny Joe,
but you got to clean it up.
You can't.
And then lenny came offstage.
Don't listen to him.
I laugh my balls off.
Yeah.
When you were talking about the colored
kid fucking shop shopping that bit up.
Shopping,
shopping,
that bit of Fitzsimmons fix.
Love it.
I love it.
Fitzy fits.
Dog Fits.
Okay.
I'm to take you down the Cape.
How many fits these?
Did we know Dave Fitzgerald?
Yeah,
there was.
But in just in Boston in general,
there's a lot of fits.
He's grew up with footsies man.
There's so many.
God Damn footsies.
Hey.
Which one?
Which fitzy fitzgerald.
Patrick Fitzsimmons fit simonds.
There's a time and don't know fit.
Simonds is uh,
the original Irish spelling of it.
And when he came to us they added
another m.
Oh wow.
I don't know why.
Hm.
So Irish heavy community man.
Boston.
So still to this day,
so Irish heavy.
It's.
Oh,
always interesting in the police force.
All fucking Irish cops,
firemen,
lot of Irish in the Pharma Department.
Politicians also.
Do you have like different flavors on
the east coast that you don't get a lot
on the west coast,
like Puerto Ricans,
right?
Like Puerto Ricans in New York,
they had a very real flavor.
Absolutely.
This is like a layer.
They got style.
We have the Mexican like influence over
here on the west coast,
which is like a little bit more laid
back,
very laid back.
Very like when you hear trump talk about
criminals and shift from Mexico.
I'm like,
that's diametrically the opposite of how
I picture Mexicans.
Look,
man,
this criminals everywhere,
but I find that Mexican people that I
meet like especially like in America,
down to Earth,
easy to hang out with is very common
family,
family oriented,
very common friendly,
hard working work and sense of humor.
That's not a bad group of people by any
stretch of the imagination.
It's like what the Republicans say.
They want Christian families that stay
together and work hard.
It's you gotta.
Yeah,
Mexicans,
right?
Well,
they're brown though.
I mean it's really like they're from
over there.
It's so stupid.
It's so fucking stupid.
I mean,
Ted Cruz is,
first of all,
his last name is Latino and he's born in
fucking Canada and for a guy like that
to be against immigration is so
hilarious.
Like,
let's look at your name.
You Fuck,
look at Laura.
You're born rubio is anti immigration as
well.
They're all crazy.
Well,
what about fucking trump?
Who's got two wives that were one was
questionable about her legality with her
green card,
he could potentially be married to a
woman who was guilty of illegal
immigration.
She's hot.
Who Cares?
She is all that matters.
She's still hot.
She's hot enough to.
She's got the Willy Wonka golden ticket.
It's between her legs and she gets in.
Nobody's going to deny a girl.
Looks like that.
A green card.
She let her in and she does the foreplay
yourself?
Like he just says 10 minutes and she
gets a little oil.
Takes a hot tub,
gets a finger going down now hard.
She doesn't penetrate.
Works the outside candles.
Candle Kenny g music or is that just my
one little soft sack.
Seriously.
Xm and those are real tits apparently.
Well,
who gives a fuck?
I do,
but you're not going to touch them.
So who cares because the top,
it just has that little softness to it.
God,
she's gorgeous.
Yeah.
Well,
it's fucking beautiful.
You know her story.
She like grew up in a fucking farm in A.
Yeah,
that's how you got to get them.
Where was it?
The Ukraine?
Romania.
Finland.
Holland.
No,
she's Flemish.
Flemish.
After he fucking throws a hot pick one
in her neck.
She's from Slovenia.
So she was dirt poor and uh,
you know,
she was,
she entered some beauty contest and she,
uh,
she got seen.
They started sending her on commercials
and all sudden her New York and she
fucking was booking work and the Donald
saw at a party and she was with a guy
and he was with a girl.
He made his move.
Diddy.
Yeah.
It's kind of guy.
You want running president?
That's it.
Guy Who can close the guy you got.
It's the guy you got.
That's what you need folks.
Amanda can close close deals.
Trump trump shirt,
man.
Period.
Just him.
Just show him his story.
Animated.
That's the commercial.
Him taking the girl going upstairs.
Let's just go for it folks.
Let's hit him.
He doesn't even take his boxer shorts
off.
They're wrapped around his ankles.
He's got like expensive gold tip socks
on and he probably keeps his dress shirt
on.
Mostly white rail and her from behind.
Yeah,
and it says trump.
He closes deals.
It's just an animated.
She's got a laptop on her back.
Yeah.
He's just banging the shit out of her
and doing stocks and tweeting at Rodeo.
Donald,
you purge.
You will lose a rosy.
Sad.
She has to remind him.
He's fucking Donald.
Couple more down here.
I'm down here to receive Dick.
I work on my pussy all day for you.
I squeezed a squeeze.
I print by shave.
I perfume.
I'm here to make juice.
I'm going to squeeze and make juice.
We're gonna.
Go to jail.
That's the president's wife.
That's all right.
That's a real possibility.
I mean,
I'm not sure if it's the wrong one
either.
I.
The one thing that I like about trump
becoming president is the one thing that
I like is that it throws the whole
fucking golf fucking food cart.
Just chucks it over.
Figure this mess out,
right,
and they've got to figure out a way to
come up with a candidate that makes
sense to people.
It already has though.
I think the gop,
the gop new after the,
after Obama got elected twice the gop
that they needed
the black vote,
the Latino vote,
they needed to come more to the center
and uh,
they didn't.
And so trump happened and now you gotta
think that trump is like the real slap
in the face.
They didn't receive after the black guy
won twice.
Yeah.
They know they've got a,
they've got a seriously.
They're to lighten up on some of these
social issues like abortion or gay
marriage.
They gotta let it the fuck go and not
worry about bathrooms with a girl and a
boy is back.
Shut the fuck up.
Yeah,
I agree.
That's why it's moving to immigration.
Immigration is one that taps those
primal fears of invaders and it's not a
real issue.
Faders,
right?
They're taking jobs and they're raping.
They take all the fruit off the trees.
The trees are bearing the invaders of
taking all the good.
That's a weird thing too.
I feel like these are the last hold outs
to the inevitable conclusion that
borders are retarded and we can't have
borders anymore if we all want to
pretend to be even.
We all want to be like,
we all want to be like kind.
We want to Holland to treat Finland the
same way.
We want Japan to cheat,
to treat China,
that everybody just treat everybody like
they would if we were one gigantic
community.
Well,
you're not gonna.
You're never gonna have that.
If you have these places,
we can't go in and he can't get out and
they can hold you like you can't just
cross the border and you have to go to
this place.
They check your bags like what are we
doing?
Like what are we doing?
What w?
What are these like,
whoa.
This side,
we've done a better job of managing
resources and we're not going to pick up
the slack for those brownies.
Brownies with Kuka,
Rochelle music,
drinking tequila down south of the
border.
We're going to put up a wall.
Hey had the same opportunities as us and
they squandered them squandered for
right now.
That makes sense.
I understand the impulse to do that
right now.
I understand if you're the person who
doesn't want your house broken into or
you're the rich guy lives really close
to San Diego and you're like,
fuck that.
Keep them over there.
I get the sentiment.
But when you look at it,
if you take yourself out of the picture
and you look at the overall picture of
human beings on the planet,
inevitably those things are going away.
This is only a matter of tower of Babel.
It's got a,
I was in Seattle the other day and I use
this,
um,
this lens thing on phones.
Have you ever done this where you can
take your phone and you hold it up and
you can,
you,
you can hold it up to like an image like
a that has writing on it and it
translates it Italy.
Yeah.
That's amazing.
Incredible.
It reads it the photo.
You're your fucking menu.
You could put up a menu in Italian and
it'll tell you what the entrees dude,
dude.
So yeah,
it's amazing.
It's incredible.
I mean,
how long before there's something where
when someone talks it's immediately
translate east real time back to you and
you just put a iphone ear thing on.
What's that?
You said they have it.
They have it already.
A fucking moron like me comes up with it
like,
hey,
how about you do this?
We've been working on it for 10 years.
Here's my test.
If something's good.
Elon Musk is involved.
Yeah,
it's hilarious.
The translate foreign languages in real
time.
That's amazing.
Wow.
This gadget companies crazy comprises
two ear pieces that easily fit into your
ears.
Die.
It's fucking amazing.
So when people are talking in $29,
dude,
what's that called?
I'm fucking buying one tomorrow so I can
stay on.
My kids are saying about me in Spanish.
It's called waverly something we really
last year that made it waverly labs.
Wow.
I'm on that shit.
Damn.
This is amazing time to be alive when it
comes to this stuff.
But here's the thing.
All of these things in theory should
bring us together and break down
barriers.
Look at Brexit.
They tried to pull together and then
fucking,
you know.
Yeah,
well you know,
wasn't an well,
I need to talk to my friend Steve
Hilton.
I've had him on the podcast before
Hilton hotels.
Well he know he,
he's,
he's a politician from England.
It was her while he was David Cameron's
righthand man.
Oh yeah.
And now he runs this thing.
I'm over in America.
He runs a startup called CROWDPAC.
Well,
you kind of can find out what the
candidates stand for you like you put in
what you stand for,
like what heard about green,
it tells you what you should vote for.
One candidate best represents your
positions on these things.
But he actually thinks that the brexit
thing is a good idea.
I haven't talked to him,
but uh,
I know that's what his opinion is and I
want to,
I would like to hear it.
I want to know what that because I don't
have an opinion.
I don't either.
I don't understand.
I understand that they don't want people
to be able to immigrate freely all
throughout Europe and come to the UK.
Those were England had an issue and I
understand that some people think it's
racist.
Um,
but I don't know enough of it to have an
opinion.
I think it's a populist movement.
I think it got a lot of energy from the
wrong people and if the focus was on the
wrong parts of it,
but economically,
I mean they're,
the pound dropped in value.
Where are the euro dropped in value when
they pulled out?
And uh,
you know,
a lot of countries said they're not
going to do business with England for a
while.
They're going to punish them.
See,
but this is what I'm saying.
If you look at what we're talking about
when we're talking about borders,
that's essentially like a,
there's a dissolving of borders,
right?
That's essentially what they're saying.
Like we're just going to start saying
these borders don't mean anything and
you can move to wherever the fuck you
want.
Just pop back and forth from each one of
these countries.
In Europe,
we're a union like the United States in
a lot of ways and really probably how
much bigger.
Who's bigger?
All of Europe in the European Union or
the continental United States.
What's bigger physically?
Well,
Russia's got a ton of fucking land,
but a lot of it's just ice.
Right?
But as Russia considered Europe?
No.
Is it Asia?
Russia is Asia.
Is it?
Yeah.
Oh no shit.
See we're learning.
You didn't know him.
I thought it was pretty Europe.
Dare you racist.
You're so lucky.
They're white because you can be
ignorant about them and no one gives a
shit.
I'm like,
well,
you know what I mean?
Because the Russians are white,
like,
called a racist.
How big is United States compared to
Europe?
Uh,
United States is 9 million.
One hundred 61,923
kilometers.
Europe is 3 million.
So we're 788.
So yeah,
we're three times larger.
Allegedly.
I mean close to it at least.
Yeah.
Wow.
Two and a half times the size of
European Union.
Okay.
But either way that's a.
These are,
we're talking about two fairly large
countries.
Still reeling from the fact that
Russia's not in Europe.
I can't fucking believe that I'm this
old and I've been to college and I don't
know that we'll.
Do you know the story of the Mongols?
The Mongols people are now leading.
Listen to this.
Are going.
No,
no,
no.
I know.
I read.
I read the gang biography.
Do so one of the greatest fucking books
of all time.
Do me a favor and everybody who hasn't
heard of this before,
do me a favor.
Listen to Dan Carlin's hardcore history
series called the wrath of the con and
it is fucking epic.
It's mind blowing story,
but Dan Carlin covers it like it's a
masterpiece.
It's a masterpiece.
It's five episodes on Kangaskhan and his
family and all the crazy shit that they
did.
Yeah.
Oh my God.
The crazy shit was how much they
conquered.
I don't know if they were the biggest
conquers in history,
but I'm a European Russia.
Okay.
Russia is a European or.
The question is blah blah,
blah,
blah.
Located in Asia,
a part of a larger part of it's huge.
Landmass is located in what is Asia
while more Russians live in the
countries.
European part.
Oh,
so it's both interesting.
Disagree on the far western part of it.
So Moscow's the European part,
close to that.
And then the rest of.
It's an interesting,
interesting.
So is that all that all that sounded
knowing that much about the globe,
even though I do know the earth is flat
because I go on Youtube,
um,
ms dot paying attention to that.
No.
Oh,
you don't know now you don't know.
You don't know.
There's a fucking enormous group of
people in America in 2016 to think the
earth is flat and that is a big
conspiracy where Haley,
there's tons of videos on it.
There's tons of videos on how satellites
are not real,
but their planes in low earth orbit,
they just keep flying around
transmitting data.
They just constantly find these planes
around lying about their being
satellites.
Yeah,
it's,
it's it,
you know what it is.
It's like hipsters that are dressing
like the from the 18 hundreds and
cooking like different 18 and now
they're going to go back to scientific
beliefs from the 19th century.
Wow.
Look at all.
It's all connected back up a little bit.
They're young.
Jamie Lukow.
China just sort of rolls into Europe
like that and that's why when you look
at the,
all the different kinds of languages to
exist in that one area right now,
it's a ton of languages and it used to
be a ton of currencies.
I mean,
I try.
I remember traveling around Europe.
I had a backpack for six months when I
was 18 and I just hopped around and my
biggest nightmare was changed.
Going from Belgium to fucking Holland to
London to front every day you had more
money than you had spent.
So now you got these Franks he can't
fucking use,
so you've already paid a commission to,
to get your money into French francs.
Now you've got to pay money to convert
it to pounds,
so you're getting double whacked on
every transition.
And uh,
it was fucking huge pain in the ass.
I'll just try and do is get laid.
And so then they switched over to the
euro,
made everything way easier.
Yeah.
But now that England bailed,
no more European Unions,
so no more euro either.
Now the day you got to keep using the
euro,
d c is going to continue on.
They're just not going to have England
part of it,
but I'm saying no more euro in England.
No,
I don't think England ever converted.
I think they stayed with the pound all
this time.
Yeah,
they were always half in.
Okay.
Oh Shit.
Yeah.
We are better than you,
right?
We are not sure if we want you joining.
We've got these lovely pictures of an
inbred queen on a five quid notes.
We've thought it over and decided to
just let you to sort out on your own.
It'll be over here in England.
Thank you.
We're going to have a little tea like
you all fucking there.
They're fucked for awhile.
Already hates them.
Are you going to address your
fundamentalist problem?
Yes or no?
We will no longer be backing up your
socialist program.
MMM,
but one day it's going to be what it is,
right?
One day they're going to figure out how
to get the whole thing and make it.
One might not be in our lifetime,
might be a 100 years from now.
Will they abandoned the idea of that's
the only way things are going to be
fair.
It's like now because the one way thing
is things are not fair.
If you live in a really shitty country,
if you're really a war torn part of the
world or something like that,
you're not allowed to just move anywhere
you want.
Yeah,
because everybody would just live in
Miami.
They're just,
they're just a good spot and they were
just so overwhelmed that bitch,
you know,
they're just fucking float on over and
Miami would just be like a crazy market.
Yeah.
It would just be chickens running
through the streets and people playing
music in their underwear.
Way more extreme than it is now.
Shoulder to shoulder on the beach.
You'd never get anywhere if you like
Rio,
but Kansas would be like,
she always took global warming kicks in
and everybody's heading up to the
fucking Midwest.
Wonder,
well that's sort of how it's always
been.
I'm not excusing people.
One thing that I think gets lost,
this whole climate change debate,
climate change for the record I think is
definitely real and I think it's
definitely being a being affected by
human beings and pollution and what
we're doing to the environment.
I don't think that's.
I don't think that's deniable,
but I think that that said,
we should also look at.
Forget about what people have done.
I think just we should also be aware
that this fucking thing changes and it
changed.
There's ice ages back when people were
knocking sticks together and hoping to
start a fire and still created a nice
age,
had nothing to do with people.
The thing fluctuates,
it gets weird and you can go through
periods where North America is covered
in a mile high sheet of ice.
Like was the case 10,000
years ago.
That's hard to for people to get in
their heads.
Ten thousand years ago we weren't doing
anything as far as cars.
There was net hairspray.
We weren't shitting on the earth at all
and there was a mile high sheet of ice
that covered most of North America.
Yeah,
that's the Great Lakes.
That's all that those flatlands,
those were plowed over by giant glaciers
just smoosh the earth.
That was 10,000
years ago.
There's statues from 10,000
There's shit in Turkey that's.
They've discovered that 3000 years older
than that,
so during that time,
without people doing anything,
it's changed radically,
so I'm not exonerating people,
but I'm saying what be a real fucking
stupid part of this global warming
climate change issue is that it's become
some sort of an ideological debate
between the left and the right,
the left to blame everything on on
people and the right who say it's all
bullshit or some of them say it's all
bullshit or offer solutions that really
don't take into account the environment
there,
but the reality is this fucking planet
is volatile,
right?
Once again,
it's become a debate where one side has
to negate the other side for their truth
to be the only truth.
Exactly.
Yeah.
Well that,
that does happen with people,
man.
We.
We get super rigid and not just an
opinion,
but in a side and aside to take.
I think we have to be whoever,
whoever's right,
whoever the wrong about global warming,
we have to fucking wake up as so how
much resources we have left and how
quickly we burned in them.
Yeah,
because there was this something about
China,
one area of China that's dangerously
close to having.
It's a oceans ecosystem.
Completely collapsed due to overfishing.
Yeah.
Feel like.
Because you think about what the ocean
is,
right?
Let's,
let's,
let's turn the ocean into instead of
this gigantic,
massive water,
let's just have it a,
a,
a tank.
The size of this room and all these
little fish in here.
Fucking and making new fish and then we
throw in a few little tiny boats with
scoopers in them.
I,
they,
there's scuba round and scoop fish up.
Just scoop fish up and hopefully scoop
fish up in enough time.
That gives the remaining fish time to
fuck and make more fish and then they
scoop fish up and then they scoop fish
up and they keep doing this.
Like how long can
you do that before there's no more fish?
Well,
it turns out it's about 50,
60 years and where they are at right now
is there's some places that are
collapsing.
They're like,
wow,
there's no more fish.
Like,
because it's not just a fisher catching,
it's the ones that feed on them.
Well,
it's not only that,
it's like there's no sustainability plan
and a lot of parts of the world is suck
out as much as you can fuck the world
and just do it because that's how you
make a profit and they just,
they're just international,
international waters.
There's like all this.
A real weird debate about,
you know,
how you can control people fishing and
what you can do and they have a hard
enough time like sea shepherd has a hard
enough time catching people killing
whales.
Do you know how they're getting away
with killing whales?
They pretend that it's scientific
research.
Yeah.
Because every country is allotted 20
wells a year or so.
Yeah.
So these boats go out and they slaughter
whales for scientific research and then
they sell their bodies.
Yeah.
It's,
it's like a loophole that allows them
the profit still off killing whales.
So like,
you could never do that if I could,
will was like a land creature in North
America where,
you know,
it was this beautiful thing that walked
by when and we knew there was like only
a few of them left.
Like,
wow,
keep that thing alive.
How cool it is.
They never heard people.
They don't,
they only eat plants.
Know what happened to the orcas at
seaworld.
People are boycotting the park because a
couple of them died and it should
because they were on earth because they
were on land.
Yeah.
Well not only that,
I'm one of them tried to kill themselves
themselves.
Really?
Yeah.
And one of them like came out of the
container and laid on the ground,
tried to kill it.
So it makes sense,
man.
They're supposed to be smart.
Yeah.
It's tough because the ocean doesn't
have.
I mean he'd go back to borders at least
if you've got a border around a piece of
ocean,
you can say we can save our piece of the
ocean.
But if China does that,
there's ripple effects and eventually it
affects all the oceans.
Yeah.
You can't tell people where to go unless
they have guns.
If they come over in a battleship,
right.
That's where we can tell them,
hey,
fuck face.
Right.
But,
but have like a fishing boat probably
get pretty close.
Yeah,
but they must have like waters that are
designated for international fishing.
Yeah.
There is
looking at part of the problem with the
marine life and whatnot,
and I got to this article that says that
they're doing land reclamation,
which is also destroying what things are
adding new islands in an area in between
different countries where they already
have islands,
which is a breaking some international
water laws,
which is what you guys were just talking
about.
The United Nations is mad at them for
doing this because it's.
It sounds like it's kind of blocking off
area that should be open for anybody to
navigate.
Oh,
that's interesting.
So they're closing off channels for
various for various reasons and they're
calling it land reclamation.
Yeah.
I was trying to find out what they were
doing with the land.
How do you make an island?
That's a good question.
Like you have a barge and you just shoot
sand until you just keep pumping.
Just throw all your pool.
We have to.
We have to deal with a billion people's
poop.
What should we do with it?
Let's just make an island.
Let's make mushroom island.
Just fucking stack it up in a fucking
magic mushrooms.
We've seen that one in Dubai.
Yeah.
There's just a series of islands.
There's two of them.
One of them that looks like the earth,
like all the continents,
but uh,
are they floating or those?
Granted,
not whether they're grounded,
but they built them up.
Yeah.
But you know,
I mean,
it's so cocky.
Any fucking change.
See,
they have a sea wall around them and see
how the sea wall has like those little
vents or water could come in and water
can come out,
but it'll stop like a giant surge.
So it allows water to escape so they
don't get overwhelmed.
Wow.
It's really interesting the design,
but most people think it's not going.
Mother's got to take it off,
take it back,
going to take it all back.
And she took him down here.
Mother's going to go,
oh,
I think I want to clean today.
Give me that seawall.
She's just pulling out bentleys and
Gucci bags and she is doing a concert
there.
Dead.
Sucks them into our water.
Ask.
Let's try it again.
Take you down to the raw molecules and
try again.
The patriots suck sand from one part of
the ocean and blast.
That's incredible.
Wow.
Scroll down so I can read what it says.
It says,
this added 144 miles of shoreline to
Dubai.
Holy Shit.
One hundred 44 miles of sand.
Let me tell you about the ecosystem.
They're just sucking sand.
There's living things and that sand at
the bottom of the ocean.
I'm whatever,
Dude.
It is really weird how much money they
have.
Dubai is like a fascinating exercise in
what you can do if you have all the
money and no class,
how dare you?
It's like the Vegas of countries.
The Vegas of countries dies.
Hilarious.
Whenever I see a young kid and if,
if Ferrari driving down beverly late at
night,
last little clubs,
all I think is Dubai.
Sky's got a credit card from his dad and
Dubai and he's just tearing it up,
going to clubs and just fucking thrown
out a credit card for endless bottles of
champagne.
There was one guy,
um,
I saw at.
There's a Beverly Hills Hotel,
I forget which one it was,
but I went to dinner there and they had
these cars that were from Saudi Arabia
with Saudi Arabian plates.
They either fly him over here or they
ship them over here and it's apparently
the sign of like a super baller is that
you keep your Saudi Arabian license
plates on your boot.
Gadi Iran as you drive around Beverly
Hills,
right?
So you're on Beverly Hills
and a car that cost over a million
dollars,
a million dollars and you have these
plates that are not illegal at all and
no one says shit to you.
Yeah,
because it's obvious that you're some
prints or some salts in type.
Dude.
He had bill burr has a video up on
youtube about,
he was in Paris and they,
there's a big thing there of guys from
the Middle East flying their cars and
exactly what you're talking about and
there's just blot and there's like a
convention of them and it's blocks and
blocks of,
you know,
million dollar cars and it costs $50,000
to ship it over.
Wow.
And uh,
and they'll bring over three or four
cars each.
Wow.
That's super baller stuff.
Yeah.
But isn't that one of those things where
it always accelerates?
Like everything continues to accelerate.
Like what made you a super baller in
1996 does not make you a super baller in
2016.
You've got to get on that next level.
Shit.
Yup.
And then next level should,
if you're a guy from Abu Dhabi or Dubai
is every year I fly back to California
and I spend the summer there.
I don't want to be here for the summer.
So I fly my boot Gadi I fly my foot
already.
Yeah.
And just have some ball or pad.
Beverly Hills.
And all you do is come all the time,
just shooting loads and the bitches
shallow.
They smell the loads.
They smelled the jewelry,
the vayd on.
Well,
if you a girl and you are,
I'm a loose morally,
if you are okay with doing sexual things
for money,
if you can get a lot of money out of a
gentlemen.
Yeah.
That's uh,
that's the kind of gentleman that you
would want to get because that guy could
give you a million dollars.
You won't even notice.
It doesn't even think about it.
Some of these guys will put you up in an
apartment just for when they're back in
town.
It's a good move.
Yeah.
Solid.
He's also super baller.
Super baller.
Three cars flying on a plane.
He's getting his feet done the entire
time.
Smoking a vape pen with sunglasses on.
You get a pedicure on the plane.
Right?
And just setting it up.
He's got a phone on the plane.
You can have phones on planes.
Remember?
We should always have phones on planes.
Did we?
Oh yeah,
that's right.
You could use it across the $100 or
something.
Call people,
you remember that it was in between your
seats and this guy,
he's calling three people in Hollywood.
That's all he's got to deal one gets the
bitches one gets to,
you know,
gets this place prepped.
We and others like and it's all set up
for him.
He just shows up.
Yeah,
goes from fuck.
They tell them which cool bar he's got
to go to.
Which restaurant tip in every $100
bills.
It probably has a nickname for ourself.
Like the raptor.
Yeah.
Calls people up the raptors in the air.
Prepare yourself.
Here he is.
Look at him.
Oh my God.
I called this guy.
This is the guy called.
He's got a gold.
And what does it.
What kind of gun is that?
It says rich kids of Dubai.
So this kid's got some gold plated
automatic rifle.
He's sucking on.
Is that a vape pen or a hookah?
Because hookah.
Hookah gun is the hookah.
Oh my God,
you're right.
Oh,
so it's not a real gun.
Of course it's not.
So that's as hookah and he's on a plane.
So he's smoking a hookah on a plane or
is that a limo to limo?
That's a car door next to his leg.
I thought it was an actual plane,
but I mean that's him.
Wait,
you talked to him?
No,
no.
I make this guy up and he's real.
I made them up.
But he exists yet rich kids of Dubai.
I didn't know that.
That was a instagram page.
It's not a super risk to beverly hills
or whatever.
What's that watch worth?
I don't know.
Is that?
Well,
you'd have to talk to someone who.
Who understands them because that's
another big Dick Contest,
I'm sure is what you're watching.
Oh yeah.
That's a big thing with those,
those types of gentlemen.
And what kind of car you have,
what year your car is.
I wonder what the most sought after
woman is among those guys.
White.
Blonde.
Blind.
Why trumpy looking girls?
Yeah.
Like maybe,
um,
maybe they'll really turn out a Kansas
girl like daisy dukes,
cowboy hat and one of those,
one of those flannel shirts and ties in
and not.
Yeah,
she's got boots and he pulls his be God
if they run to some Texas gas station,
right?
What?
She's buying worms because she's fixing
to go fish and you catch your own fish.
I have plenty of fish coming my yet.
Look at that guy.
Who's,
who's,
um,
how many of them speak English and how
many of them are Russian?
Led big.
I need answers.
Yeah,
man.
These guys ball don't hate Jamie Hayden.
Lot of hating on.
They're just punching lucky.
God.
I love guys that write stuff like that.
Like you would kill to hug one of those
girls.
How about this dirty bitch?
I want to join you ladies.
See folks,
it takes every kind of people that the
song wasn't.
It takes for people to,
to,
to.
What does that.
We just pull it up right there.
I wanted to join.
Oh well,
don't be mean.
Don't go onto her page.
Don't blow her up.
She's a freak.
You can't stop freaks.
Yeah,
that's the whole thing.
Those clubs that,
that,
you know,
uh,
that entertain those types of people.
Oh yeah.
You know,
they have to change that.
It's always got a new name every three
years.
It's always like one word,
utopia or whatever.
And uh,
and they have to do multimillion dollar
renovations have to or else people
stopped going there.
Yeah.
And it's an unknown strategy.
It's like what people like,
you know,
Cock fest is opening.
It's opening next week.
You come in and Scott Fest,
is that a,
is that at Aria?
Yeah,
it's amazing.
You know Dj fuck faces there.
Dj fuckface left the trop.
Yeah,
he's,
he's done with them.
They fucked him.
It's just bullshit.
They scratched his records.
How much do you want?
Eh?
They're like essentially like if vegas
had like a test,
we test people for ecstasy before and if
they failed you wouldn't let him in the
club.
There'd be no one in the front.
The clubs like it is a weird thing.
There's a lot of drinking for sure,
but the amount of people that are going
to see those crazy dj shows that they
have in vegas and probably Malian up out
of their mind.
Probably.
Jamie,
what would you ask?
You're a young man,
would you say?
How many people that are going to see
these,
um,
vegas musical shows are doing ecstasy?
80 to 90 percent.
That's what I'm sure,
if not more.
Not all of them because there's people
that don't.
I just want to do it,
but almost all.
80 to 90 percent son.
That shit fucks up your head,
doesn't it?
Molly?
I allegedly.
I hurt you.
Crashed the next day.
Really hard because your brain has been
just soaked in water.
The chemicals you get soaked in a,
you get dopamine,
then you get withdrawal from it.
Right the next day.
Look at this excess Las Vegas unveiled
$10,000,000
makeover.
Holy Shit.
Look at that place.
That's like the ice palace and frozen.
Let it go back to one of those pools
where you just stand in like Ian Edwards
joke.
You don't swim in that pool.
That's hilarious.
That place it's awesome.
Um,
yeah,
I did.
I did ecstasy once and uh,
I never did it again if fucked me up.
I had a great time when I was on it
though.
And I learned a lot of shit.
Learned a lot of shit about.
I'm like,
you take it just dissolves insecurities
like they're gone and it like gives you
like a,
an insight into like the structure of
the building,
of your personality,
like takes away the walls and you're
like,
oh here's the support frame and this was
like the door with it.
Everything goes through like,
oh,
okay,
I got it.
So like insecurity is all this,
like a guard that's constantly on the
lookout for your peace of mind and for
your go eat your self esteem and for
your relaxation.
Like it's good.
Got You covered.
I've got you covered this.
So this thing is like,
this tension is around you all the time
and it manifests itself in a bunch of
different ways and one of them
insecurity.
And when you take that initial ecstasy
experience and it dissolves that
feeling,
you go,
oh,
like there's a lot of weird shit that
people trip on for no reason.
And me,
me weird shit that I would trip on for
no reason.
That makes you wonder like,
how much time am I wasting with these
really poor thoughts?
How much energy?
So much energy.
Like I was thinking the other day,
what is it like to work at the national
enquirer?
We'd talk about like blowing out massive
amounts of energy on nonsense.
Like I was at the counter,
I was picking up some fruit and A.
I went to the supermarket and I stopped
in the line to put my stuff on and
there's this national choir thing that
says I sold coke to Matt Lauer and below
it it says
Larry King,
Larry King's wife caught cheating on him
and then there was another one.
There was some other scandal on it too.
It was like,
this is hilarious.
Larry King gives a fuck if his wife is
getting laid it probably pay the cab
fare.
You Shit me.
So he doesn't have to disappoint her one
night.
I don't know.
I deserve it.
Poor Larry.
I saw him on a show recently.
I think it was like Colbert.
Remember we were watching it.
Jeremy,
what was that show that we were
watching?
His body looks very strange.
Very strange.
Just curling right.
Well,
it's way worse than that.
It's,
um,
there's something going on where there's
no tissue in between his bones.
Yeah.
So like when he sits there he'll like
sit down.
Everything just sort of collapses like a
folding chair and assumes these weird
angles.
Like you sitting there and he's got like
one arm up,
like,
look at that.
Look at that picture right there.
Yeah,
that's one.
But there was another one when he was on
the couch.
I want to say he was on the couch of the
Colbert show.
I want to say that's what he was doing.
Um,
and it was just fucking strange to look.
I like,
oh Larry,
like you got to lift some weights.
Like you gotta you gotta use the Yoga
Shit though,
isn't he?
How much older is he denounced alone?
How much older?
How much?
I got to think Larry King's 85 years
old.
Really?
Stallone is what?
Sixty five.
Oh,
he's 82.
Wow.
Well it was great.
Why He's worth worth one point.
$5,000,000,000.
Wow.
Holy Shit.
I didn't know he had that kind of
bank.
Powerful Larry King.
No wonder why he doesn't care if his
wife cheats on them.
It's like,
who gives a fuck?
I'm over here coming on money.
Right.
That's a lot of money.
He still works.
Who likes it?
I guess loves it.
I saw him in the Sirius building one
day.
I mean those weren't.
Not a lot of high profile shows there
and he,
he's there doing interviews.
It's interesting guy that that's his
wife.
Yup.
Would you hit it
x rated,
cheating scale?
Not.
If he's.
Don't go to that page.
How dare you?
You're about to click you little
gossiper.
When I was getting at is that like
imagine working in a place where that's
all you're doing constantly.
Like what is that?
Well,
it's almost like they just take darts
and they through.
They have two different targets in.
One is the person and the other one is
the activity will also day.
They're allowed to make shit up.
All they have to say is a source told
us.
Yeah.
That's all they have to say and they're
protected sources.
Told us Adam Sandler was shoplifting.
Tells us that bet.
Midler is anorexic and they get sued.
All the time for making shit up.
Don't fuck a scientologists because
they,
they come hard.
Do they come home?
They went where they went after the Sun
Times in uh,
in England with the Sun Times print.
Well,
there was,
I think Rupert Murdoch's company that he
was gay.
Well and scientology fucking took him
home.
Yeah.
How rude.
You don't have the pockets say anything
right now.
It's just so funny.
We should write a paper like that.
Just about comedians though.
How so?
Just dirt on committees.
We'll make it up.
Yeah.
What would we call it?
Common Inquirer just ripped them off.
Yeah.
To find the link to the article.
But when you click on it,
it's gone.
Last one.
Oh Shit.
Which,
which article?
The scientologists even took down
articles about the lawsuit.
It's off the Sun Times.
Websites will only probably sued sue the
shit out of somebody.
The uh,
whatsapp Gawker went out of business
because of that one lawsuit.
Because little loves bunch we.
Yeah.
Because of a whole cogan his wife.
But one lawsuit fucking mean was a big
industry.
Yeah.
One lawsuit took him down.
Didn't they get hit for over 100 million
bucks?
Something like that.
Just because they show it showed his
cock 140 million.
Was it a video or was it.
It was video.
Video put up brand stories about it.
What were the videos?
Also some like really defiant statements
like someone asked him about like
underage girls,
like wasn't.
What was the.
Wasn't there a question about that?
I think you said some about black guys
or something whole Cogan?
No,
no,
not,
not that.
There was something else.
There was a different thing.
What I'm talking about is the wood.
They asked him like,
at what age would you not release that
video?
Yeah.
The guy who got sued,
the Gawker Guy.
Oh yeah.
They uh,
they asked him something and he gave
this really defined response,
you know,
like I,
I,
I'd fucking,
I'd put it up,
I put it up,
definitely put it up.
I forget what it was,
but I remember listening to it like,
Ooh,
they're going to get this guy.
You can't just do that.
You can't even,
you can't even say you put an underage
sex tape up.
People are like,
Oh,
you're just out of control.
Yeah.
What did he say?
Okay.
Yeah,
he's down.
And uh,
and then they sued him personally to
Hulk Hogan sued him personally for like
35 million bucks and then sued Gawker
for like 100 and whatever,
million bucks.
And then Bubba suit also magic bubba.
The love sponge coming after you.
Holy Shit,
I'll give you whatever you want right
now.
His show,
he's a good guy.
Fucking great.
It's great guy.
I did his show one time and I walk in
and I just come in on a red eye and I
walk into the,
uh,
studio and it's out in the middle of
nowhere.
It's like in the fucking brambles and
you go and it's like I've shack and you
walk in and
there's some pas and they're smoking a
joint.
They get me high.
Everybody's drinking pabst blue ribbon.
There's a midget on the cow little
person on the couch who's pissed
himself.
And I go inside.
It was like,
it was like training day.
I go inside and they,
uh,
Bubba pulls out a 12 gauge handgun and
Israeli handgun and he starts waving it
around and everybody fucking runs out of
the studio.
I go,
you just fucking around.
Right?
And then everybody runs out like babies
not fucking around.
And he,
he had a,
he had a stripper or a whore in a van
who drove up to like this corporate
offices center and she was giving guys
hand jobs for free,
but they were playing the audio live on
the air guys in suits and briefcases,
getting handies in a sweaty,
windowless van.
Wow.
Holy Shit is the best.
Later asked by an attorney for Hogan.
If there was a situation which a
celebrity tape might not be newsworthy,
Doloria responded.
If they were a child,
the attorneys then asked him to specify
a child or under what age dollar Reno's
responded for.
No cases are won and lost on shit like
that.
It wasn't a bad hole cut in anyway.
I didn't think it was that young.
I thought I was.
I thought he was talking about like a 14
year old.
My brain was probably so disturbed by
that.
I turned 14.
That is disturbing it.
It's probably on coke.
Let the guy go.
It's probably a doing antidepressants.
Lots of cocaine run into thing like
Gawker.
You got to be wired up.
Got To be on it.
Yeah.
It's like that guy who used to do the
um,
a spring break videos.
Remember that guy?
Spring break videos.
Girls Gone Wild.
Oh,
February.
He was fucking wired till.
Same kind of an operation.
Just couldn't stop,
couldn't get enough.
Couldn't say fuck you to the press and
the public enough.
He was a renegade.
Well that guy was kidnapped in his house
and his house was broken into and you
got raped,
like a guy raped,
raped him with a dildo because he had
video taped his girlfriend or something.
Probably something along those lines I
think I heard of was a sister.
They got like sodomized the guy and made
him say some shit on video and so he did
something to this guy,
sister.
I'll find this story.
Of course that's going to happen.
You live a life like that.
That's going to happen one day.
Yeah,
it's probably going happen.
Will definitely happen.
Wow.
Girls Gone Wild.
Remember that.
There was a moment where that was.
If like you try to do something like
that today,
no one would give a fuck.
You mean the,
the Internet.
There's plenty of shit that you could
watch.
It's way more crazy than girls gone wild
that you would never have to pay for and
you wouldn't have to get releases for.
There was a brief window in time,
a brief window where you could just run
through and that ran through
and sold videos that you could buy late
night on a website.
Girls Gone Wild and you would watch
these videos and people would pay for
him to remember jerking off to the
commercials.
They were so guy broke into his house.
He pulled his pants down,
strategically placed that Dildo in his
ass.
Strategically,
I don't think there's a strategy
involved,
folks.
You are really loosely using the word
strategy.
I've got a diagram and a,
there's a theory of Einstein's theory.
Whoa.
They found the guy,
it says,
uh,
the,
the masked man who later turned out to
be sexy in pr.
Why isn't sexy?
Why has that sexy Hollywood con con man,
Darnell Riley then tried to blackmail
francis for up to $500,000
for the tape and he would have gotten
away with it too if it wasn't for Paris
Hilton,
who was also being blackmailed by Riley.
Wow.
Holy Shit.
She was an idiot.
Hooper friended him and he introduced
him and introduced him to her social
circle to begin with with Paris has
help.
Police were able to arrest Riley who
copped a plea and is currently serving
eight years in prison for robbery and
extortion.
The irony is that he'll probably be a
free man of for a few years,
in a few years while Francis will likely
be serving a term on tax evasion
charges.
What year is this?
Just doesn't.
Eight.
He's not in jail for that.
Oh,
okay.
So this guy's out to the end of eight
years.
I wonder if some guys were strategically
putting Dickson his ass.
Why they probably strategically.
Why do you say this guy is a.
that's the whole thing is weird.
So they.
They've met a con man and the con man
found out with Joe Francis lived and
fucked him in the ass with a Dildo.
How rude.
I'm speaking of Florida.
Can I plug my sweet guy?
You did it.
Yeah,
please do.
I,
uh,
we were talking before the show is this
week.
You're doing that?
Um,
the water now.
A lot of data.
It's a great room,
a great room.
The eighth through the 10th of
September.
I'll be down there in room.
It is,
it's,
it's rowdy.
Yeah.
It's a fun Gig.
I'm not a big fan of a casinos now.
We've talked about that before.
The show started,
like the Indian casinos and native
American casinos.
They're dark to some.
Some bizarre about that.
Yeah.
And when you got to walk through that
every night to get to the shell shell up
with a weird vibe you've absorbed.
It was absorbed.
A lot of different energies.
Walked into that room.
I stayed at the hard rock last time I
was in Orlando and this couple next to
me was fucking the shit out of each
other.
You could hear it.
It was great.
Yeah.
This guy was laying some pipe.
I wish I met him in the hallway.
I'll give him knuckles.
Yeah,
but what if the door opened and he came
at.
I was trying to find the book.
You won't fuck.
I'm weird.
She's doing now.
Like he was.
He was pounded eller.
Pam was like,
Oh fuck.
Oh fuck you pay me.
I was like,
whoa.
It was going on for quite a while,
so it was like,
this guy's really laying pipe.
That's fucking great.
Now.
He's definitely took vitamins.
It was definitely a shape.
Yeah,
it's pounded her for awhile.
What?
I was like,
there's something about that.
Well,
you're
ever,
ever cat or cats will like hide under a
couch,
but their tails hanging out.
That bitch I see you.
He'd pretend to you when someone's
fucking in a hotel like that.
Yeah.
All right.
No one's around.
No.
Everybody can hear you.
Hey,
everybody can hear everything you say.
Everybody can hear you.
You're.
You're basically broadcasting to the
people above you.
Below you in to each side.
I've stood outside doors,
I'll for sure I have.
I've walked that walk next door and
stood right outside the door solution.
You get the double door connecting rooms
and you open your door,
get it glass,
pull your pants down.
Doom,
doom,
doom.
Also Cleveland.
The eighth through the 10th.
So what day is this Hollywood improv
that's going to be the,
uh,
the first through the fourth of
September this weekend.
Greg,
who are you working with?
A couple of white guys.
If it's Florida,
I would imagine.
Oh,
this white people in Florida.
October of your new special White Castle
in Florida.
A Cleveland September eighth through the
10th.
That hilarity.
He's good.
Good,
good,
good.
Good.
Good restaurant.
Really?
Nick Costis runs the place.
He makes the best,
best,
best food of any comedy club in the
country.
That's strong words.
Where else do you think there's good
food?
Like Lacey's comedy magic.
Oh yeah.
That's good.
It's excellent.
It's a great restaurant,
right?
Flappers.
I haven't eaten a flat.
Oh yeah,
I did know.
I hated flappers once.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
There's a few places now.
The improv try to do a barbecue joint.
They tried to have like fake fucking
fake old Westie Shit and colored the
roadhouse they had like,
like rusty saws on the wall and stuff
like this theme come from.
What are you doing?
What corporate meeting dreamed up this
idea.
I know this isn't a farm more retarded.
It just puts me in the corner of.
In the room.
What's on first?
Barbecues in.
Make sure the waitresses take one side
of that.
Overall off,
she was drunk at the bar.
Like Jean.
What do you do in the wild west?
What do you do out here and with the cow
pokes in our barbecue sandwiches.
I don't know.
France,
the old western bar.
This,
this,
this boards weathered some old shitty
wood.
There's a little hitching post out
front.
Yeah.
You show up with some shoes that were
professionally scuffed.
Yeah.
You brought them to these like poor
immigrant children and they just threw
rocks at your shoes.
Yeah.
Go play soccer in these front.
Our solute look like.
They're like,
you're a man of the world.
A worldly man.
Then don't forget a Calgary,
Calgary,
Alberta.
Fucking love it up.
September 22 through 24 at Yuk.
Oh,
good
gig.
Oh Shit.
Yeah,
that's a good gig.
Is Fun.
Podcast festival on the 25th.
Now this is going to be back in La.
Oh,
on September 25th.
That'll do it.
I'm like,
how you did that?
You went podcast festival for anything
confusing.
You said people.
It gives them the thinking like,
is this in Cleveland to right?
And then you say in La like,
oh no,
I have to rethink everything.
Oh,
it's in La.
It's.
I try to take people on my journey.
Here's,
here's what my life is going to be for
the next 30 days.
It's going to be lonely.
You should bring guys in the room with
you.
I know Cleveland.
I am Jff.
Harris has opened for me and Cleveland.
That'll be great.
You know that Guy Jeff Harris?
I probably met him.
Yeah.
Good guy.
Good guy or know we just moved here.
He was where he was living in the
Midwest.
I can't remember which city he was in.
There's so many new guys here now
there's like a guy.
You see someone a couple of times like,
ah dude,
what's up?
Right.
You know,
I know.
Yeah.
What's up?
Like you've worked with them on the road
or.
No,
you've seen him at the Improv or see
there's like there's always new people,
you know,
like the comedy business.
As far as like the amount of comics,
I don't think there's ever been more of
us now.
Right.
When you think,
well there's a ton of rooms,
there's a lot more people making a
living at it,
that's for sure.
Yeah.
Which means there's more people that
try.
Plus you've got like,
you've got that whole,
like you see b mechanism that creates
comedy by making classes of people learn
comedy and then they all start going out
to the clubs and massive waves like
fucking like crabs running into the
ocean.
Right?
Sea Turtles.
Yeah.
There's a lot that escape and they don't
have real commitment.
They just are dealing with because like
they've blocked out this time before
they get a sitcom writing job or before
they go into a,
you know,
auditioning for movies.
Like there's just this period that
they're going to do standup.
There is a.
there's a thing that drives real comics
crazy and it's that.
Yeah.
Like guys like you guys like Marin
brings that shit up.
Like there's a lot of guys get real
upset.
I like people with alterior motives that
also do standup.
Like standup is a sacred thing.
That must be.
You must commit to yourself only to this
art.
I get some dark art,
like dad,
they're going to try it out for a while
and then they're going to move on to
other things.
So it's fucking losers.
It's like I'm a middle aged woman in a
bar.
Some honky tonk and guys use me a lot.
I just want.
I just want to meet a husband to good
man.
I just don't know why.
How come?
Why not but fail or you coming in my
mouth.
This is just not what I wanted.
I wanted.
I know it's what happened.
I'm not.
I pull my head off when you jam it back
down.
Swollen love just.
Well I'll give the head but I just want
some kids to.
It's too late,
baby,
or 56.
No,
no,
no.
There's a moment in Russia.
She's 64 years old.
She just had a baby.
She had her first baby,
naturally natural childbirth to the
Lord,
and she drank a lot of keifer.
He ever heard of that?
It's a culture.
It's like a yogurt.
It's real good for you to justice
system.
It makes your rap as a baby.
I know.
I got three or four eggs left.
Had a period last summer,
be well.
It was a hemorrhage.
Blood clot.
A cyst.
Burst wasn't a period.
It was a polyp just dug deep hemorrhoid
that leaked from her asshole into her
vagina through the wall.
It's so such a heavy flow just pouring
out Uracil,
but she's sticking tampons.
Some residual,
some of it.
I swear this came out of my vagina.
I think I've been feeling cranky.
I'm heavier than ever.
Look,
I'm moody.
I am Diane [inaudible].
She just passed a fucking.
Your spleen ahead period.
Just came through.
Uh,
but I used to date this fella and he had
a hook like Dick and I think you wore a
hole in the wall of my vagina with his
Hook Dick and that is where the blood,
my vagina,
but just not coming out of my vagina.
But I'm definitely having my parents
show up.
Took it in the ass last night real hard.
But that's not why I'm bleeding.
That was my choice set my month.
I just felt like give him a treat and
then she would have she punches herself
so she can show them that she's
bleeding.
No,
look,
she's got pliers up there 10 minutes
before.
Did you see that video of that woman?
She was suing her ex fiance,
some billionaire character and they got
video for beating the shit out of
herself on the bed.
Put surveillance cameras in the bedroom.
Oh Shit.
She's wailing on her own face in the
bed.
Wow.
Like wailing on ourselves.
That's awesome.
Screaming,
kicking weight.
And who is the guy?
Some rich guy who's breaking it off with
her.
She's like,
Oh yeah,
motherfucker.
Well,
what do you think?
Did you talk to Stan hope about that
whole thing with?
Um,
yeah,
I did,
but honestly he on that.
He wasn't there.
I'm stan hope.
Uh,
he wasn't there when it all went down.
You know,
if,
if he ever did really whack that chicken
the head.
I don't know if he did,
I wasn't there.
Look at this girl with this.
Show it again,
Jamie,
but just show the beginning because the
beginning is ridiculous.
Watches.
Oh my God.
She's insane.
And then she starts throwing these
tantrums and then doing it again and she
does it a bunch of times.
Oh my God.
She just keeps wailing on her own face
and screaming and yelling.
Dad,
that is a woman out of control and
there's no one there.
She's doing that shit by herself.
So she's making noise.
The neighbors will hear it.
I don't know.
I don't know if she's doing that.
That's actually a smart move.
You open up all the windows,
do it so the neighbors can hear it.
Beat the shit out of yourself.
Your neighbors called the cops.
You come out.
He left.
He just left five minutes ago.
You just messed up.
Wow.
Meanwhile,
he had surveillance cameras.
You get to see darkness sometimes and
things like that.
Woo.
That's dark.
Yeah.
Ooh,
I got.
I beat myself up in jail once I was,
I got arrested for fighting and uh,
the cops were being fucking assholes and
they wouldn't give me any food.
And then,
uh,
and then he,
he reached in and grabbed my hair
because I was yelling at him and he
bashed my head against the wall a couple
times and I wasn't bleeding.
So then I punched myself in the side of
the mouth and I made myself plead and I
got out and they just like check me out.
Nobody cared.
It wasn't like a big investigation.
They just felt like did on my shirt,
like 16 clever fellow Wilson.
It was a way to make this better.
I see an opening.
I'm going to take the whole police force
down.
He grabbed my fucking head.
I just can't prove it.
Feel justified.
My embellishment.
I bet there weren't cameras back then.
The cameras they did have.
They just draw with crayons.
Yeah,
they were terrible.
It's like a sonogram and I mean any
surveillance system from the 19
eighties.
Yeah.
Kinda shit film was that you were
looking at vhs tape and the 19 eighties.
Oh,
you remember that movie Jamie?
That vhs movie,
that horror movie that people told me
about it.
That's awesome.
Do you ever see that movie?
The vhs.
It's like found footage.
Like,
look what we found,
uh,
the uh,
something which projects or which
products like that.
But vhs is just,
it's just a horror movie,
but it has this one,
um,
one segment of it,
there's like three or four segments,
how many segments.
There's one segment was this girl this
and she plays a this demon that really
loves this guy and she's Kinda hot and
she meets this guy at a bar and she's
just really strange and they get back to
a,
an apartment and they're all drinking
and this guy starts banging her and she
turns into this demon and kills them
all.
It's fucking wild.
And they've decided to make a whole
movie is the best part of the series.
The vhs series by far.
So they decided to make a whole movie of
it,
of this one character.
Apparently it's out.
Is it called like sirens or something
like that.
The sirens was an Australian movie with
is a bunch of those sirens movies.
But I think this movie is called Siren.
It might be siren and it might be on
Netflix.
I can't imagine a deeper emotional
change than fucking girl and having her
turned into a monster that's killing.
You know what I mean?
It's so well done.
One second.
You're just,
you're
and you're in your,
you're feeling confident.
You're income.
Like sex is being in control as you're
and you're making her feel a certain way
and then all of a sudden the fangs come
out and you're,
you should dick shrinks.
You got to get out of there.
Well,
that's part of the problem.
And the thing like,
she fucks this guy.
She's fucking him,
but she kills all his friends.
She likes him.
She keeps saying,
I like you.
I like it when she goes to suck his Dick
and his dick is soft and she gets upset
and she's covered in blood.
She was covered in blood sugar,
giant teeth or head is grown,
so her forehead and split down the
middle or skin is split down the middle
because her head is grown and she's got
all these teeth and she's sucking his
cock with its blood caked all over her
face.
She was like,
no shit,
and she's like upset.
Why aren't you hard?
It's like porn.
No,
no,
no.
You don't see it.
It's like from his perspective is like
glasses on where he can see it.
Siren clip goes on the run and attacks.
What does that mean?
Yeah,
I think that's the movie.
Fuck.
Which is the vhs?
Yeah,
directed it releases in theaters.
December second 2016.
David Bruckner video on demand to.
Okay.
So it's going to be on demand December
second.
I hope it's good.
Play.
Play like a little clip of it.
See if you can find a little clip of
the,
uh,
the scene in vhs.
No,
not this one.
The original one and the original scene
where there's the,
where the girls,
like,
I like you.
There's like a clip of it if it's like a
trailer of it.
So this was,
uh,
this was,
did it get released or went straight to
that release,
but the rest of the movie wasn't good.
Yeah.
It's like this one part is really scary
and it's fucked up and like wild and it
gives you all these feelings and it
lasts for 20 minutes or maybe a half an
hour at the most.
But this is her,
like what?
They play it for it so you can hear it.
It's really creepy.
Before she turned into a.
Oh,
it's just that,
that's it.
And she kept doing that to him and he's
like,
yeah,
I like Youtube.
She's like,
God,
I can't.
And then as they got alone together and
then on their friends and everyone's
drinking and then when she turns into
this demon and kills them all,
it's fucking horrific because it's all
seen from the first person perspective.
It's all seen from this guy's eyeglasses
that he's wearing.
He's wearing these video.
That's her.
When she was sucking his dick.
Wow.
He's freaking the fuck out.
I was so good.
It was those Gary,
you know,
demon seems stupid.
It seems really stupid that something
can turn into that,
but look how bizarre is a black widow?
How bizarre is a spider that eats her
mate?
Yeah.
You know how bizarre is a lot of nature.
That's absolutely real.
Yeah.
There's a lot of weird shit out there in
nature of things changed.
They morphed.
They become a different thing.
Yeah.
If there was just a small percentage of
women that when you fucked him,
they became demons.
You don't.
You don't know.
You don't know until you get them hot
and they're out there on the dance floor
and they're fucking really shaking it
because they can't wait to become a
demon.
Yeah.
They're really trying to draw you in.
I like it.
And you're like,
dude,
I'm telling you man.
No,
she's Puerto Rican.
She doesn't speak English.
That's a demon.
I'm telling you.
Demon.
Six weeks.
There's no demons,
bro.
He got to take the chance,
but people still fuck.
Absolutely.
With guys still get drunk and take
random women home that say,
I like you.
There would be girls that would pretend
to be demon so they can get guys.
It'd be like,
you never heard that some gay guys
become a bug catchers or bug chasers
where they try to get HIV.
No Shit.
Never heard of that.
No.
It was like a real phenomenon and the
gay community were like reckless gay.
Single guys would actively try to get
HIV for fun.
No Shit.
Obviously this is not representative of
the entire gay community and I'm not
being any way discriminatory.
What I'm saying is that these,
these are real people that actually did
this because people.
Very people are nuts.
Well,
if there was a demon because it was just
one small percentage of the population,
it's less than one percent of one
percent.
Yeah.
If you meet a thousand people,
one of them's a demon.
What are the odds?
I dated a girl whose boyfriend died of
AIDS.
Oh,
same thing.
East condoms.
Demon aids.
Same thing.
Use condoms because he died of AIDS.
Yeah.
Whoa.
Like she might have caught it from him.
Well,
did you get nervous now?
Didn't think about it.
When you think about it,
getting aids or getting ebola or
syphilis is lot like having a demon in
you.
Yeah,
like this thing,
it's a living thing.
You're hosting this entity that's trying
to consume you.
You have too much energy.
I feel like it's not going to suck your
Dick and bite your balls off,
but it's just like you invited it in
slowly and you buy it in through a bus.
Yeah,
little drunk.
She had acute feet.
That'll brown ones.
Next thing you know.
Oh,
and then you go to pee.
Fuck is going on.
What is going on?
Why is my Dick hard?
Fuck my records says nothing.
It's nothing.
Don't be.
Don't be scared to just being God you're
so.
She looked fine.
She didn't look sick.
Don't be paranoid,
man.
Then you got to work for a couple days
like,
why am I sweating?
Am I sweating?
Is it hot in here?
No,
it's freezing.
It's office is freezing.
I feel hot shit like,
okay.
I think I'm okay.
God,
I'm so tired.
Let me check my voice.
I like you.
Yeah.
Voicemails.
I like you just slowly but surely the
thing eats your body away and isn't that
how I'm.
Al Capone died.
He died from syphilis.
Did I believe so from everybody not die
for Vd,
you know,
like you watch,
you watch game of thrones or any of
these things and just reminds you of
like back then nobody use a condom and
they went to whorehouses constantly.
What color gained gave me pussy smell.
Pussy ass hole combo smell too.
People have back then.
No running water.
Oh,
Al Capone.
Spent the last year of Zach trust
sentence would had been reduced to six
years and five months for a combination
of good behavior and work credits in the
hospital section being treated for
syphilis.
Oh,
he was released.
He slowly deteriorated while staying at
his palm island estate in Miami on
January 25th,
1947.
He died of cardiac arrest.
So yeah,
syphilis got them.
Huh?
You know,
that's a slow demon.
Is it syphilis?
So,
but it's a demon.
It's like it's the same thing.
Yeah.
I mean it's not going to talk to you.
It doesn't come from hell.
But it comes from here and it does the
same job,
just takes a different form and it's not
as terrifying to us for some reason.
But if as many people died from demons
has died from the flu,
we'd be shitting our pants every day,
like thousands of people in this country
die from the flu.
Nobody's out there freaking out.
It's like,
imagine if you go to cvs and get an anti
demon shot.
The same amount of people,
the same amount of people who died from
the flu data demons there.
They have like garlic rings at the
store.
You have to go and throw them on and
there's crosses everywhere you go.
Yeah.
We would be in a state of terror if,
if demons killed as many people as colds
do.
Right.
And it's all through sex.
Like with the cold.
He didn't even get laid.
You just got something on a subway.
Well,
yeah,
I mean what percent.
Okay.
Let's,
let's take a guess here.
How many people ever like over the
course of human history have died from
vd?
How many?
Millions of people?
Millions.
A hundred million.
$100.
Million.
I think you're probably right.
Let's say 100 million people have died
from venereal disease worldwide.
How many people think it is every year?
How many people is like hit a year?
Syphilis,
Shit like that.
Kill.
Well,
AIDS is still tearing up to third world.
A million.
A million worldwide every year.
That might be high.
Few hundred thousand dollars.
It certainly wasn't in the aids.
I don't have no.
Honestly,
now that I'm saying this,
I'm realizing I'm totally talking out of
my ass.
I have no knowledge of what the actual
numbers of the aids crisis where I had a
guy on my podcast a long time ago who is
a biology at the University of
California,
Berkeley and he does not believe that
HIV causes aids and of all the people
that I've ever had on my podcast that
created more like people angry at me and
controversy.
I just wanted to talk to the guy because
I don't understand the argument.
I don't understand how one person can
have this point of view that all these
other scientists and biologists don't
have.
What the fuck is that guy's name?
Downer?
Well,
the president of South Africa,
does this believe that HIV causes aids.
You has names.
Duesberg.
Touche Bird Duesberg.
Duesberg said German gentleman.
And uh,
what he believed is that it was a
competent.
He said that I'm doing a shitty job
paraphrase,
but what are you saying?
I know I clear my throat too much.
I'm gonna.
Stop America want people that are
listening.
A lot of the old radio shea butter
coffee.
I don't want to admit it because I love
it,
but I've got to stop drinking it.
Let's just drink water for podcast.
It's annoying.
It's annoying to me and I'm clearing my
own throat.
Anyway,
I think it's part of your chart.
This Duesberg Fella thought that it was
a good idea to tell everybody that uh,
HIV was actually a weak virus and that
it was a symptom of a deteriorated
immune system rather than the cause of
it.
A deer have a,
created a real immune system and he
believed that the cause of the
deteriorated immune system was a bunch
of different recreational drugs these
guys would take.
And then there's a disproportionate
amount of these men from these areas is
parts of town where they were doing a
lot of drugs and how to have sex.
Yeah,
email nitrate and crystal meth and all
this different stuff,
which is apparently amyl nitrate in
particular.
All that stuff's apparently devastating
to your immune system.
And so it was his belief that the HIV
aspect of it was just a symptom of a
deteriorated immune system from drugs
and that they were saying that that
caused it.
But how the fuck can you sneak that by
all these different scientists?
It just doesn't make sense.
Like I obviously don't understand the
argument and he is a tenured professor
at the University of California,
Berkeley and apparently he's made great
strides and cancer research.
He's actually a very,
very intelligent guy.
But when one guy has like a theory like
this and everybody else's like,
fuck you,
like this guy to be.
It's just doesn't seem like it could be
possibilities.
Right.
Does that.
I don't know.
I don't understand it,
but it doesn't make sense to me that one
guy has figured this out and that.
So when I had them on match,
people got so angry.
Yeah,
I think it's so.
And it's a perfect guest.
They're like,
blood is on your hands.
I'm like,
well now he's a tenured professor at an
Ivy League school.
I think he can bring them on.
I got news for you.
If you take it in the ass because of
this podcast,
you're going to take it to the ass
anyway.
So don't tell me.
Yeah,
fucking raise.
And you were already had amyl nitrate in
your hand.
You're ready is no way.
I am swaying your decision to get but
fucked up condom.
I am not.
You take responsibility for your own
actions.
You son of a,
b,
you standing in the gay woods.
Come on.
Listen to the podcast on earbuds.
How ridiculous is that idea?
Yeah.
Well I,
I wanted to know.
I mean someone said that you should do
it with a qualified medical professional
so that you could have someone to
counteracts as claims.
That is a very good point and one I
probably should have taken into
consideration and I probably would try
to do that today,
but back then mean this is many years
ago when I was doing the podcasts,
I couldn't believe the guy even wanted
to talk to me and I was like,
this is going to be great.
I always wanting to know what this
fucking crazy dude believes because
everybody would always tell you to do.
You've read Duesberg.
He had a thing in spin magazine.
HIV doesn't cause aids,
Bro.
I was like this article in Spin magazine
I read,
which was um,
wasn't that the Penthouse Guy?
Didn't he have something to do with
Larry Flynt?
That's hustler.
Yeah.
Anyway,
there was this article in it about
Duesberg and about HIV and I remember
reading ankle and is this even possible?
Is it possible?
Those things are really sketchy and
dangerous for people like Uri who
doesn't know Jack Shit about the human
body,
but does.
How much do you know about diseases?
Very little.
I know I got gonorrhea once.
Did you?
Yeah,
and in my mom's car and I went to this
club,
went to this nightclub and I saw the
classic fucking move out of a movie out
of a John Hughes movie.
I see a guy hitting on a girl and he's
really annoying her.
So I walk up and I go,
skews me,
do you mind if I talked to my
girlfriend?
And the Guy Kinda just nods and walks
away and she looks at me like a fucking
halo comes over my head.
Half hour later I'm fucking her in the
back of my mind that I mean like dad and
uh,
you know,
pounding,
pounding away and uh,
you know,
real real,
like to sexual,
like she was more into it than I was
almost nice.
So then,
um,
I go home that night,
I sleep maybe three hours and then I get
up the next morning to go caddy and I'm
out on the course and I mean,
is that fast?
By noon I get a burning sensation.
I stopped at the ninth,
we'll shack to take a piss and it was
like acid coming out of my penis and I
got in.
I had a fever of like 103.
I had green muck in my underwear and I
went to the hospital and they gave.
They diagnosed it immediately.
They're like,
you got gonorrhea,
you got the clap.
Buddy gave me a huge shot of penicillin
in the ass and it went away.
Just went home and slept.
Woke up was gone,
but then the girl who worked in medical
records at the hospital lived in town.
She was my age,
fucking told everybody I had gone to.
I couldn't get laid for like a year.
She
lock me for a year.
In all fairness though,
you would have done the same.
You only got to tell one person if you
found out that she had Galleria,
girls wouldn't even make out
mate.
I was like,
fuck yeah man.
Any reason to keep away from you when
you're young.
Kids are ruthless and when they how they
bought,
dumping and re gather their
relationships back up again.
Alright God,
they're ruthless in how they break up
with each other or how they shun one.
They'll kick one fucking duckling with a
limp.
The shit out of that duck kicking into
the pond.
Fuck you look forward to like kicking
someone out.
Don't ever fuck that guy again.
You don't have to tell me.
Right.
And those girls are so vulnerable at
that age too.
And if you somehow or another work you
way back in just to keep it a secret and
we have to keep a secret that we're
seeing each other.
Yeah.
Like it's.
And you know,
after a while no one's going to care
anymore but they can't right now.
Yeah.
They can't right now.
And you have to sneak in just to go on
dates with other guys.
She goes on dates with other guys and
says she feels like shit and she goes
home early and then she fucks you.
Yeah,
like barely.
She's wondering why she's doing it.
She's waiting for one guy to come along
that she goes on a date with earlier
that it's like preferred to you.
Yeah.
Right now you're like barely hanging in
there.
Yeah.
You're just the second year you're
almost on the bench.
Gonorrhea boy.
Fucking disease can change the course of
your life.
Right?
Like that could have just changed your
confidence.
You don't want to bet it did for the
better.
I'm sure it does.
I'm thinking about that.
I think it made me more cautious about
condoms.
I'll tell you that,
that,
and I also bet it helped you deal with
like,
like the,
the inevitable moment on stage where you
say things that people don't think it's
funny and you have to kind of have some
personal sovereignty.
Yeah,
that's a good way to develop personal
sovereignty.
You become an outcast.
Girls.
I'm gonna fuck you up.
And you're like,
hey,
I have a mirror.
I know I'm not a fucking freak.
Like what's going on here?
Like this is bullshit.
Yeah.
And then forcing your way back.
You're handsome little fella when you
were young.
That's all right.
So what'd you had?
Hair.
Full head of hair.
Bright Smile.
Clean deck after awhile.
Oh,
I used to quit.
Quit,
quit.
Quit it.
He's got a good vocabulary.
He's a sharp kid that fitzsimmons sharp
as a tack.
He's at the cow loon and Sagas up route
one.
Me and sally went to see him uproot one
who's fucking hilarious.
Do you knew how I stumbled across a
tweet the other day,
Larry?
We're poochie.
Oh yeah.
Probably a good tweet.
Well,
I think it was what it was was I was on
Tim Macintyre's twitter.
I was like searching,
you know,
Tim mcintire,
Boston comic.
I was on his twitter feed for whatever
reason.
I was bored and I'm reading some funny
shit that he had an interesting stuff
and you know,
you do that.
You go on like a little twitter timeline
thing.
And I ran across a,
it looked like a facebook message from
Larry Ripu who when we were kids when we
were starting out.
Larry was kind of a legendary character
in Boston.
Who,
uh,
was he,
he got a,
like a full time gig with nick's comedy.
Stop.
We're all.
He worked with Nick's comedy stop gigs.
He was one of those few guys,
a few guys that got that package.
Remember they gave him like 500 bucks a
week and they would just work them to
death if you do what?
But he knew that 500 bucks is coming in
every week and never had to worry about
work.
He worked and he was so loose because of
it goes.
He was like,
it was in the.
Allowed them to do other gigs too
because I know I did.
I know I did some other gigs with him
too.
That may not even nick's comedy stop
gigs,
but for the most part he worked for them
and he was such a character.
Yeah.
So I had like a mullet and a belly and
he would strip down to a bikini at the
end of his act.
Didn't he have like a regular job too
for a long time?
I'm sure.
Like post office or something,
something like that.
Yeah,
that place,
man,
I don't want to live there right now.
It's like I don't want to do that in the
winter now.
God Damn was a fun place to grow up.
Yeah,
it was.
Because if you weren't performing,
he were watching good comedy.
So one night that was a good night out.
It's amazing.
Like as adults,
when we're looking back on it,
how it looks stupid,
like you literally couldn't ask for a
better place.
We found the best place that the best
time.
Right.
So almost like if you are in some sort
of a simulated reality and you wanted
to,
uh,
do the dream of a struggling but
eventually becoming a professional
standup comic,
where do you want to start?
I want to start out in the golden days
of comedy in the 20th century and I want
to make a living out of the gate.
I'm going to drop you off in Boston.
He's going to be cold.
The winter is going to give you
something to bitch about.
People have short attention spans.
They want you to give it to them quick.
They have very little patience for
bullshit.
You couldn't be indulgent.
There was no room for indulgence,
you know,
made you really appreciate it.
Attention spans.
It's fucking freezing outside,
dude.
Get to the point.
Yeah.
And it was like you were given the
opportunity,
but then like you could get stage time
and you could get seen,
but to really work,
you had to fucking command the stage.
He had to do your time.
You had to consistently perform.
It was like all these things that just
made you get your 10,000
hours as Malcolm Gladwell says,
like that was,
that was us getting our 10,000
hours.
Yeah,
and it's really like for the most part
it's like 10 years,
right?
Like 10 years for you know,
what you're doing really didn't even
then you're pretty shaky.
Think Seinfeld said 14.
He might be right.
It's hard to call,
but it's a,
it's just so interesting.
When you look back you're like,
wow.
It all sort of played itself out.
Like it.
Like it was a program.
It's like if you were a folk musician in
the village in 1963,
so it smells way better.
Yeah.
And those guys never made any fucking
money.
Yeah.
Folk musicians.
There was a few that broke free,
right?
Like who was,
who was like a big folk musicians.
Joni Mitchell,
right.
Trying to.
Mitchell is a bad ass bitch.
She was about aspects that album blue I
would put up against any album in
history.
She had some really creative vocals to
really creative lyrics.
What a voice range.
Yeah.
She's someone that you don't really
hear,
you know,
like you could be at any given bar at
any given night and here,
sweet home,
Alabama,
but what are the odds that you're gonna
hear?
Like chuckie's and love,
right?
You know,
California.
Yeah.
That's some great songs.
Moody songs.
Yeah.
Like they command your attention.
Can't passively listen
to Joni Mitchell.
Yeah.
There's a bunch of pave paradise.
Put a parking lot,
Greg.
That's a great song.
Yeah.
It's interesting,
man.
The,
the,
the what we've just seen pass in our
lifetimes.
The different styles of music and the
different,
like errors of music,
of the eighties error.
Like when we were in high school,
it was all like van Halen.
Yeah.
You know,
it was all like was always in and out.
Good.
But it was hairbands,
you know,
def Leopard,
foreigner,
foreigner feels like the
name.
Every band member I was selling to
foreigner.
Yeah.
Company and
Btl bad company had that song.
A shooting star,
right.
That was the song that every kid thought
was about right?
Nah,
Nah.
John was a school boy when he heard his
first Beatles' song.
Right?
Yeah,
me too.
I think it was from there,
it didn't take him long and then it's
this whole thing about him becoming this
rock and roll star
and then dying like real young died in
his bed.
There's like four songs that are like
that.
They were about like,
uh,
you know,
here's a story of chuck and Diane.
It's always about like the midwestern
kids that go out to la and then they
break up and she becomes a whore and
yeah.
Yeah.
John Cougar,
mellencamp man.
Um,
you know,
he had a lot of those kinds of songs,
right?
Yeah.
I was in Indiana once,
which is where he's from,
right?
You would think God Damn Indiana for
John Cougar Mellencamp.
It's like if Bruce,
bruce springsteen is anywhere in New
Jersey,
like at a sporting event,
and you put a camera on Bruce
Springsteen,
people are going to go for the fucking
boss,
the boss
anywhere.
He goes,
right?
Not John Cougar.
Mellencamp man.
They didn't like them.
No Shit.
Nice liberal.
Oh
yeah.
Motherfucker had asked.
The guy worked there I go,
hey man,
why are they booing?
John Cougar Mellencamp and he also,
he's generally thought of as a liberal
in like a fake Indiana person.
Yeah,
like you sold out.
Damn.
Yeah.
Indiana's conservative.
We're conservative for the KKK was born.
He's Jack and Diane like you're not.
You're not gonna gonna Cheer for a guy
from your town level.
Janice's.
Oh my God.
Yeah,
but Jack and Diane come on son.
there is times a motherfucker time when.
Yeah,
I mean here's.
He's one of those guys that like when he
was around when we were around in the
eighties and I was like,
you know,
they were pop songs.
I didn't really register.
I'd kind of.
He was a little bit laughable to me.
And then you get older and you just have
to respect,
you know,
it's almost like somebody brought this
up the other day,
hall and Oates,
we're fucking laughing stock and now I
listen to some of these songs is like,
it's a fucking good song.
You know what a lot of it is,
there's something like,
go back to that picture you just showed
this.
Something about a guy who can even pull
this off that I cannot root for.
Yeah.
He's sitting in a convertible car.
He has beautiful hair.
He is a.
his arms are up.
You as a sleeveless shirt on.
He has some sort of a bracelet on and
he's hanging back with his feet up.
He's super confident and casual and he's
a beautiful man and he's singing about
love and all these different things and
this part of you at that age would just
look at it.
You like this is ridiculous.
Yeah.
The cowboy boots selling this picture of
the tubes he had Nike's on.
It wouldn't be the same kind of photo.
Cowboy boots are important to be down
home.
He's got an old ass car too.
You think John Cougar Mellencamp can't
afford a new car.
Why is he got that fucking old car?
Because the old cars like down home.
Yeah.
He's got a car that like it.
It makes noise.
When you started out,
man,
it's like some old mg or some shit like
that.
Like you wouldn't really drive that.
He's probably get this stinky piece of
shit away from me.
It's fucking shitty car with bad breaks.
Yeah.
Where's my fucking.
Where's my,
where's my Maserati?
He,
uh,
at one point he changed his name from
John Cougar.
Mellencamp know from John Cougar to John
Cougar.
Mellencamp.
I think it had something to do with his
label.
Was trying to market him as John Cougar.
Well,
his real name is
John Mellencamp.
And when they were making his first
album come out,
changed name mellencamp song going to
sell.
We're gonna.
Call you John Cougar.
Cougar.
It sounds American.
It sounds like rugged.
Do you mean you got boots on brother
Cougar?
You are a cougar.
So they.
So they,
they sell it as John Cougar.
And then he's like,
hey man,
I want to be John Mellencamp.
Like,
no,
you can't do it.
How about John Cougar?
Mellencamp.
Okay.
The worst name of all time.
Cougar Mellencamp like did he get
married?
Married himself,
married a dude,
and now he's a mellencamp.
And these hyphenated it.
Wait,
is it melon camp or is it melancholy?
Remember Mike Sullivan.
Irwin,
of course,
he was the first guy I ever met that
took his wife's name.
He did.
His name is Mike Sullivan.
Her name is Irvin.
You became Mike Sullivan.
Irvin Jesus.
Whoops.
First Guy I ever met.
They call themselves a feminist too.
Interesting.
He had women don't even call themselves
feminists anymore.
I was asking because I've been asking
the women in the what
I was online.
It's like,
how do you.
How were you not a feminist if you're a
woman?
Isn't that just saying I want to have
equal pay for equal work?
First of all,
you most certainly are thinking very
strongly in often about women's issues.
Right?
Right.
Which I guess you have to if you're a
woman,
but I'm realistically.
You should probably be thinking of like
the humanity as a whole.
Right?
Shouldn't be really focused on one
gender
because this is just.
Just hear me out for a second.
If you're getting mad,
if we're all like completely
concentrating on one specific gender,
like female,
you can.
The concerns only of the female,
you're automatically like breaking
yourself off into a team.
This is like those guys.
They're like men's rights guys,
like that's all they talk about,
saw the tweet about,
so they want to talk about is men's
rights.
Men's men are getting fucked over in
this country and amendment.
They're forming natural teams.
It's like a windows user was getting mad
at pc or it was getting mad at Max.
It's a weird thing that people start
doing when you lock people into any sort
of a one or the other,
like right wing versus left wing,
you know,
like,
uh,
people who are straight edge versus
people like to party.
There's,
you get these locked in ideologies and
that's a big one.
Man.
That's a big one.
The gender ones a big one because pc's
are not making less money than Max.
See,
that's the thing about that whole
narrative about women making less money
than men.
I don't know if you've ever investigated
it,
but I had a long conversation with a
good friend of mine about it recently
where he was saying it wrong too.
This is the reality.
The reality is when they do these
gender,
gender income disparity studies,
the.
It's not like they're giving you the
impression that a man and a woman to
work next to each other and they doing
the same job at the woman's making
seventy seven cents to the man's dollar.
That's not what the study showed.
What the study showed is that overall
the men earned more money than the women
did if they were both working and it
didn't mean that they were doing the
same job.
In fact,
it means the opposite.
Men were choosing jobs that are much
more high risk.
They were working longer hours,
so you're comparing women who worked on
an average of 35 hours to men who worked
40 hours plus and doing different jobs,
so it wasn't.
But,
but this is the study.
The study's not that to people like
your.
I'm an accountant and she's an
accountant and you both do the exact
same job,
the exact same workload,
and you make $100 where she makes $77.
That's.
But that's how everybody wants study.
There's other studies that show like
categorically Walmart was paying the
same job.
They were paying women less.
That's entirely possible and given
individual companies that could be
sexist for sure 100 percent,
but that's not like what gets spit out.
Everybody spits out that women make
seventy seven cents to every man's
dollar.
It's just not true.
It's not like they're doing the same
jobs.
I mean you could argue that there was
one of the.
One of the best arguments about it was
that they were saying that women being
less confident or less likely to be
assertive early on and negotiate a good
salary for themselves and that could be
an issue,
but over time that sort of balanced
itself out with performance and that
there was a.
This was the hypothesis that was thrown
around by one one,
a one article,
but the overall numbers are not what
everybody says.
Everybody loves to say those numbers.
They love to heart those numbers back at
you.
That would say,
you know,
women make seventy seven cents to every
man's dollar.
It's a sexist world,
but it's not.
It's not what's going on.
It might be still a section on maternity
leave and there's things that are just,
you know,
going to hold a woman back from making
more money because yes,
she should lose her place in line
basically by taking materially I get
that,
but there has been plenty of studies of
ceos that are making the disparity in
what ceos of major companies when they
look at the same size,
companies making the same profits every
year and then you've got the woman
making,
you know,
consistently seventy cents on the
dollar.
He's generous for some of those jobs.
I know about that study.
I don't know if that's true,
but again,
you're talking about ceos and this is a
very rare segment of the population I
don't think needs any sympathy.
Right?
Like any woman who is the CEO is
probably making some fucking ridiculous
amount of money in the first place and
it's always overexaggerated how much
money they make but wouldn't accompany.
Be Ridiculous if they paid a woman less
money and she's making them more money.
Like wouldn't she leave and go somewhere
where she would make more money?
Like if she's that good,
if she's competing with men and going
right up against them,
this is the argument,
right?
Um,
I don't have the answer because I'm,
I'm,
I'm obviously just reading these
statistics and reading one of these
people said,
but I would,
I would imagine there's some deep seated
sexism that is almost impossible to
overcome mental want women as bosses for
the most part,
like subconscious.
But whether or not that's responsible
for women making less money in the same
jobs,
apparently not according to the numbers,
according to the numbers.
A lot of it is the choosing of different
paths in life as far as careers that
like that's why this push to get women
into stem.
That's why this push to get women into
technology like tech,
like silicone valley,
there's this big disparity between men
and women.
But that display was parodies.
Like real similar to how it is in a lot
of tech.
It's like most women don't gravitate
towards those jobs,
but if they do,
they find them.
There's not that many women as opposed
to men.
It's much,
much.
I think tech like look this up.
Like what is Silicone Valley?
What are the just crazy.
It's a real problem.
It's like,
is it a problem though?
But this is the question,
like that's something that people always
pair it and repeat that it's a problem.
I don't know if it's a problem or if
it's held women naturally navigate
towards different careers than men do.
I think,
well look,
none of this stuff is black and white.
I think that's part of it.
I think part of it is also when women
have role models,
they think,
oh,
well I want to be like,
you know,
I think now that you've got some big
corporate ceos,
uh,
the woman that wrote that book,
Lean in and uh,
uh,
whatever,
um,
I think it,
it,
it allows women to visualize,
you know,
and that's why I think it's important
that Hillary Clinton,
when she was president,
as much as I'm not a fan of hers,
I think it will accomplish setting a new
goal for women.
We'll do this one though,
and silicone valley men,
69 percent more likely to receive higher
salary offer.
So for their initial first salary,
69 percent more likely,
I wonder,
you know,
I guess there's gotTa be discrimination
when you think about a woman that wants
to get pregnant and have a family and
she's going to take time off work and if
you're going to have to give her
maternity leave,
that's gonna be unproductive money that
your company has to give out.
It's interesting,
man.
That lady sued.
She sued.
That is a.
I forget her name.
Yeah.
She sued Margaret Cho notions.
Who?
Margaret Cho.
She sued some company.
It was a google Microsoft.
Who the fuck she.
So she sued someone.
I think it was Google for a gender
discrimination and lost.
It wasn't the reddit.
Yeah,
she was read it after that.
She went to reddit after that.
And people were upset that she went over
there after she was.
They thought running would appear to be
a frivolous lawsuit.
Uh Hm.
I don't know.
It was frivolous,
but it lost.
Yeah.
Look,
I wouldn't want to be a chick.
Work with a bunch of dudes.
I'll tell you that right now.
Whether it's sexist or not,
I would not want to be a woman in an
office with nine other dudes that are
like scrapping and scraping to try to
climb the corporate ladder and I got to
compete with these ass Fox and they're
all out playing golf and talking shit
about my ass.
He showed up at work every day with
these cuts.
Yeah.
It's hard,
but it's good for the guys.
I hate workplaces that are all guys I've
written on shows.
Everyone.
I'm bill Maher show for awhile and it
was all dudes talking like dudes and
they start outdoing each other.
You throw one woman in the room and all
of a sudden everybody just fucking
mellows out a little bit and I think
it's more productive.
What can you equal opportunity maps?
Equal opportunity?
Oh
yeah.
Look,
it's impossible to generalize in big,
broad,
sweeping,
judge brushes,
you know,
difference between men and women.
Just there's so much variety and there's
so many people that are women that would
thrive in a high pressure,
high stress situations alongside men and
so many women that just won't.
It just,
they just,
that's not their thing.
They don't want to do it if you put them
in there that hate their fucking life,
like how many people who if they had to
do what you do would be in hell every
day,
shitting their pants,
sweating,
nervous,
can't come up with a joke,
don't think anything they have to say is
interesting.
Can't string the words together
correctly.
They get on a podcast like this.
We don't fucking plan a goddamn thing
and we've already been going for three
hours and 20 minutes.
Shut the fuck out of the time.
It's almost five.
Holy Shit.
It just flies,
flies by.
They'd be shitting their pants,
but you'd be shitting your pants if you
had to be.
A fucking accountant will go over
people's taxes
having to work.
Here's the thing about those guys.
They gotta show up to work everyday and
work all day,
almost nonstop.
Finished.
Go home,
do it again the next day,
every day.
Work on the weekends.
That's what freaks me out.
You've got to get this account done.
I hate to do this to you,
but I need you on the phone.
Twenty four slash seven all this
weekend,
but my kid,
my birthday,
you listen,
happening.
That's competent aid yet.
Phone under the pillow.
Asil B.
Well,
what'd you do
today to work out?
Yes I did.
I shot bows and arrows.
Did you went out there to do a little
archery point is proven.
You shot bows and arrows.
How many accountants got to fucking take
a little bow and shoot it at target?
It's therapy.
It's good.
Speaking of which,
let's play.
That's it.
That's my bow.
Wow.
Play some motherfucking pool.
So let's end this podcast.
Greg Fitzsimmons brought his pool.
Que Yo.
Hey,
I'm going to ask you something.
Please do.
Should I ask you on air off the air if
you can do a benefit?
Oh,
you should definitely do it on the air
and put me on the spot.
Put you on the spot for October 16th.
We're doing a benefit for best buddies,
which is a group I worked with for
special needs people.
Intellectually disadvantaged people.
We call it now.
The 16th is a Sunday at the law,
at the comedy store.
Main Room.
Are you kidding me?
I'm a fucking grown man.
Tickets are on sale by the time you
listen to this God damn podcast
simmons benefit.
Can you get some?
I'm a grown up now.
I'm doing this now from.
From now on,
folks.
I'm actually putting things in my
calendar immediately.
Nice to remind you.
I kept going out.
Fucking get to it.
I'll get to it and then I don't cry.
She's doing it too.
That's it.
You fuckers.
This podcast is over.
Greg Fitzsimmons is awesome.
Go see him live.
We'll probably be back Saturday with a
fight companion for a daytime fight this
Saturday.
It's at noon.
I think it's at noon.
La Time.
So Saturday.
We'll see you fuckers.
All right.
Thank you everybody.
Appreciate you by the cast.